parce qu'elle a shooté de cimpor
très bien alors on vous rejouez on vous
régime autoritaire de l'entraîneur
pour voir comment le niveau
l'histoire de la ligue nationale le
arriver parce que je vends que au corum
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on fait il
qu'ils font par définition mais par
si j'ai eu un succès j'ai plusieurs
lnh est qui qui n'a pas voulu commenter
je pars un ami
ça résume bien ce qu'il vient de dire le
d'important en a cure et vous dire je
est-ce que vous m'entendez toujours je
voyais comme pour l'association que jean
et guy carbonneau qui étaient au même
décrivez moi comment vous vous le
oui tout à fait il ya ça dépasse de
il retournera d'ailleurs de la fin de
des flyers sur les avait battus en
matchs du canadien puis je caton pour
l'époque très bien on va on va parler
sont venus déposer bon des bateaux ou
quartier premier ministre
généreux que j'ai rencontré deux m'a dit
lits les commandes et les anciens match
que ces hommes là votre mari monsieur
pas exactement ce qu'il pense et puis il
jusqu'au crépuscule le jour des
dernier but de la carrière de guy
belles valables six étaient partantes
compétitive qui commet ce qu'il voulait
jamais joué que ça mais moi
datant puis tu avais des frissons dans
souffre encore qu'est ce que ce que
nous a dit je pense qu'il avait déjà dit
vraiment dans les réactions des gens qui
joueur joue un peu plus de temps de
permettre ce matin de les comparer les
lafleur vous avez recueilli beaucoup de
du rock comment la plus important de
lafleur a fait parler de lui avant même
mois de janvier salle pollack craie que
style son élégance c'était un joueur
résumé de normes
c'est exactement ça pis ça va vite il
parce que je vais vous poser une
aussi je pense dernier terre
lafleur défraie les manchettes prend un
retour à montréal prévu en décembre est
scotty bowman ne semble pas plaire au
de presse la cette déclaration la en
maurice richard est en fin de vie
qu'avant pratiques tu fais
juin 14h pour ce point une presse où on
jouer avec guy lafleur huré inverse 1 un
rien qu'il ne valait plus rien ce que ce
rencontre le canadien le le 10 puis le
qu'on le pion là on va le dire toute la
cote esprits en hommage c'est un grand
détenir intronisé mais dans les faits
ça traverse les générations non
une signification
d'oxygénation du sein il y avait eu 57
bon midi et mesdames et messieurs vous
préoccupé mais vraiment la flore
téléphone élise béliveau veuve de jean
voyais à quai et se passer c'est là
ça avait été une erreur de le renvoyer
en train de parler patrick roy on va y
canadien entre 1975 et 1977 a perdu 29
parce que guy lafleur c'est le joueur de
mal quitter vibrer pour je pense tous
surpassé merci beaucoup à claudine à
coéquipier deviens pas vous ennuyer
restaurant on a on l'avait en avait dîné
j'ai beaucoup souri pendant qu'on voit
démarquer puis est impliqué dans toutes
généreux aussi envers les entraîneurs y
lui ai dit je t'aime et les gens
vous entends élise on voulait aller
d'apprendre à rien pour acquis
extrêmement sensible les gens en parlent
bons amis
swat il parle guy à
athlète qui personne performer pas à son
viennent si pareil c'est un des héros du
des bâtons des fleurs bien entendu et
un génie mécanique à l'organisation de
doit être moins de sites internet je
quelque chose à micro fermé qu'est merci
il n'y a pas eu raison parce qu'il était
dois vous avouer une chose je n'ai pas
ces témoignages en vendant d'entendre
fasse les adieux à votre mari ça va être
disputer deux autres saisons là où tout
l'organisation va faire je suis
trois on les voit la ligue je passe vous
toute paix au garage municipal et venir
lafleur âgé de 33 ans le 9 novembre 1984
dans l'imaginaire collectif du peuple
arriver là j'avais des petits enfants
question mais je lui jetez plus alain
funérailles donc ça reste encore des
décrivez mais tant qu un martien qui a
d'avoir 12 ans ses trois passages au
vedettes québécoises canadiennes
béliveau et à saint-albert et china
grave accident d'auto certains associent
vous avez rencontré à son destin mais
ya bien finie services sas france et ses
finale plus on intimide un guy lafleur
lafleur arrive à une catégorie
je reviens parce que vous avez été
qu'il aurait pu faire ce que d'autres
très ouvert avec les partisans avec le
qui est qu'ils on va s'ennuyer plus
solides autre chose c'est grâce à vous
ont côtoyé de près guy lafleur ça quel
pour son équipe
logeurs d'un joueur qui vient une fois
numéro 10 dont le grand talent tarde à
californie ne termine pas au dernier
la fleur à son retour à montréal où il
tes bras savais que quelque chose de big
spectaculaire quand on regardait jouer
c'est un nom important dans l'histoire
côté sympathique il ya même pas beaucoup
envie de connaître cet homme-là est
sait ce que je regarde de de bon sous le
parce qu'il est trop secouer pour
super héros il jouait pas de cas je le
entendre monsieur roy je pense que c'est
essence des gens qui inspire beaucoup de
génération de jeunes québécois et de
seulement ça traverse les générations ça
mathieu guy lafleur l'a
parce que guy s'était plaint dans les
retourner tout de suite merci ellis
s'est ainsi vu les valeurs secondaires
réactions depuis ce matin
glace pour produire davantage
acquis qu'on pouvait croiser au centre
les amateurs d'art qu'il de la province
c'était un goût qui avait un excellent
aura d'autres détails avec monsieur
documentaire on regarde sa réaction lors
1985 l'amour il y avait une ovation qui
à thiviers que mon grand père monsieur
la vie est courte
qu'il forme d'hommage à repenser je
journée pour dira jamais assez commun
françaises et moi aussi il ya eu maurice
béliveau madame béliveau merci d'être là
portier il y a des gens qui racontait
mais je le regrette le j'étais trop
tout à l'heure alors funérailles
merci beaucoup au téléphone ron fournier
beaucoup louis merci on va se on va se
la province de québec
avait 70 ans il souffrait vous le savez
des jumeaux à lille il ya écrit
connaissez maintenant la nouvelle guy
michelet
mais
québécois
octobre dernier arrache le coeur à tous
étaient très malades
beaucoup le hockey
convaincu que ça va être un hommage
t'aiment
joueurs ou d'autres personnes ont passé
que ce sera présenté ce soir à 20 heures
puis moi je me sente en dessous parce
amiens quelqu'un qui bat c'est quelqu'un
détails à établir le premier françois
voyez l'écran à radio canada howard et
jour lorsqu'il serait plus vieux qui
ce canal est l'occasion de rencontrer
j'étais allé saluer jama sachant qu il y
ensemble et puis par la suite c'est à sa
souvent non grande tristesse mais on s'y
puis on sait tous que ce qui passe au
soir même on annonce la retraite de guy
tous et s asseoir m on
a commencé pour lui à québec ces deux
pas entendu parler de lui le carré
joueur de hockey c'était une idole du
sérieux là on avait beau avoir des
vends mon numéro mais il est sauvé but
toute la journée avec nous justement
guy lafleur a été meilleur pointeur de
vraiment chanceux de pouvoir couvrir ses
important de le faire pour monsieur
des grandes retrouvailles auront donc
brasserie adverse était très émue la
statue de guy lafleur il ya des
canadiens
ya une image qui me revient c'est
rang qu'est-ce qui fait transaction avec
point c'était un grand homme
du hockey à toronto on le reconnaît
peuple avec le monde pimpante de la
goût vous les parties après arrêté de
l'écran des trois hommes sur la glace
plouffe vous dirait alain plouffe que
tournoi pee wee de québec avec les
parlé il parlait pas longuement mais
avait un entraîneur qui avait pas de
bien sûr à d'autres personnes mesdames
détruit come stay or ça touche qu'ils
extraordinaire
vous allez l'entendre la part des jambes
journaux de son salaire comme
ailleurs aussi des anecdotes vous en
avait-il conscience qu'il était ce point
et c'est un site c'est un une histoire
les parties étaient de vraiment un
le meilleur joueur au monde en ce qu'ils
une expérience réussie lorsque l'idée
takkal et c'est jésus marion flat rate
non seulement il regardait pas les gens
et tous ceux qui donnaient je pense que
legault merci beaucoup au revoir merci
les rassemble parce que les gens se
on avait l'impression de voir un artiste
possible sinon on va quand on reviendra
lafleur est décédé suite à un cancer
ben dewar la semaine passée mike bossy
produisent davantage rendus donner plus
par génération
beaucoup de réactions puis je vous
bell au restaurant au centre commercial
comme vous l'avez dit il était
sanguin quand j'ai vu l'article
québec c'est le hockey au québec c'est
il va rester
bonjour
parce que dans un vieux comme montréal
sur la glace on hors de la glace et
des légendes justement cette semaine si
réaction de patrick roy on reviendra au
legault qui réagit quand même sur les
lafleur aussi à bages torrado oui je ne
raciste combien de fois qu'on a vu le
nationales est ce que tout ça est bouclé
ça revient beaucoup le courage lui il se
comment vous le décrivez quelques hommes
monde dit lafleur était un tulle à guy
points de vue il parle de la vie qui
pierre bouchard merci pour ce témoignage
beaucoup de monde qui vont s'ennuyer qui
ce qui va se passer au cours des
tout le monde qui a eu l'occasion d'y
madonna de mauvaises récoltes ou puis
serait un coéquipier de guy lafleur donc
lafleur
que tu penses aux joueurs d tu penses
lorsqu'il saute sur la patinoire avec
brosse l'ida
équipes de warcq l'une des deux tours
qui qui qui était derrière moi puis qui
voiture puis lui avait une voiture
veulent être joué
puis je sentais en vous des jeunes la
de l'annoncé de sa retraite il sait pas
comptes de dépenses par les journaux le
est avec nous ron bonjour à vous
layton le monde du hack et en annonçant
peuple monidale
matches sur 240 en saison régulière dont
dans un milieu comme le québec c'est dur
jean-françois parler de l'exaltation
on voit les trois une cérémonie hommage
mais eux sont restés tard attentes c'est
souviennent de match écoutez avec leur
reparler très bon témoignage vous êtes
aussi et à toutes les 1 à tous les ans
à la municipalité tout le monde avait
des anecdotes ce matin qu'il était allé
belles années du canadien mais je
avait un lit d'hôpital chéri il rappelle
et messieurs des anciens joueurs des
regardais dans mon salon comme beaucoup
sûrement d'un cancer du poumon ça a été
réseaux sociaux rapidement ce matin les
sa carrière de rocker d'abord avec une
derniers matchs dans la ligue nationale
parlait souvent puis ça faisait ça
ils leurs résumés à merveille ce qu'on
les kings d'assange elles qui sont juste
l'histoire des canadiens de montréal
de demi fond là on avait demandé c'est
joueur spectaculaire
qui
c'est à des gosses
partisans on les voyait un peu plus tôt
ambassadeur tout ça c'était réglé mais
de haut mais il faisait partie du tissu
fenêtre et puis là j'ai une dernière
jean perron monsieur perron bonjour
soient décédés que j'attends on a perdu
prochaines heures gabriel nadeau-dubois
guy lafleur qu'on écoute parler des
dirais qu'on sent que les gens ont ce
les windows dans les estrades son père
nous en parler
avec les nordiques maicon c'est sûr que
avait duré je sais pas combien de
accessible c'était le héros qui n'était
jeu atteint un autre niveau il a vingt
qui habite toujours ici dans la
il poursuivi on a tous en tête l'image
moi je fume dans un article les tenants
fournit pas de jm puis lui avait prêté
de temps comme c'était son ancien joueur
demain reprises à 18h30 meymac et passe
sont au début des années 60 ont marqué
il se penchait lorsque quelques points
descendre sous le coude le flanc droit
travers
jouer il ya les revenus jouer est ce que
en choisir un pour toi c'est le rend
centre bell après bien soir oh oui
souhaiter mes sincères condoléances à la
je sors une personne d'appareils de
provenance il était pareil
me supporter le dha à ce que je faisais
ont des souvenirs
comment ce qu'il commande quels rapports
carbonneau est avec nous guy carbonneau
passe trouve et on vous en a on vous la
soit des photos des anecdotes à me comté
fouillant les images de sa carrière en
avec la fougue c'est très drôle qu'à y
bien sûr la famille doit accepter mais
patrick roy vous représentez sa wii
c'est un grand monsieur mouche des
officieux 15 côté bowman mandat n'est là
et à des gens qui sont venus ce matin
complète pour les mois pas très sport
cette semaine guy lafleur le monde du
forte une autre vie je pense
devant jean béliveau et deuxième buteur
larme à amener ce que j'aimerais savoir
te voir accepter de participer mais mimi
les jambes et mieux tous
travaillais à l'autre station à l'époque
aussi qu'il suscite est servi aussi
que c'est juste et il est tellement
de pour répondre aux attentes et y est
en compétition avec eux pour les
roquesteron pédant même chose que lui
de gens qui nous écoutent ou dans ce
minutes là qui est lui dans sa teinte
attendait depuis le mois de novembre
extrêmement difficiles qu'il a eue
m haies ou qui des fois il était en
personne elle-même zéro parce que ce
important merci beaucoup
un but prendre un café il y avait eu de
trop quoi répondre finalement il prend
l'effort était toujours là il y avait
remarquable ça quel est le plus beau
je sais pas s'il y en a encore qui vont
qu'il accroche ses patins sur le chat
allé chercher j'ai dit quelque chose
encore plus ce qui ne pouvait refuser
grand père leur père
finances filâtre de toip comme on dit
une religion c'est notre sport national
porter des billets à du personnel du
besoin de se recueillir le premier
photo avec l'instance yadh la plus jeune
pourquoi il avait autant de talent
des dégâts que pourrait avoir la vérité
social puis il s'imprègne est déjà et il
équipe junior b puis avec les as de
comme j'ai dit ça ça m'a marqué
faisait du sens pour gagner plus souvent
des agressions mais pas plus mais pour
une dont une saison dont au cours de
sur les réseaux sociaux le chef
par dont il ya énormément de québécois
bonjour batterie vous vous qu'un quand
vrai de lui de ses participations aux
municipalité donc anecdotes intéressant
populaire par axel auxerre c'est réglé
après quatre saisons de 30 bureaux - la
trois en six saisons consécutives de
collègues on a eu déjà des témoignages
que tu as fait plaisir bien
charles d'aiguillage des en gaspésie
crache pas que tout ça n'est pas normal
nordiques contre les canadiens et seront
deux grandes vedettes du rock et d'un
moment qu on se levait avec lui il ya
l'heure un début plus difficile on parle
puis marc il des buts de cette façon le
essaie de dire et à sa façon des hommes
l'imaginaire deux fois en trois ans il a
débarrasse mais il y aurait pu avoir une
pour raconter les anecdotes comme à ceux
vous aviez avec lui le quand vous êtes
exactement je pense que c'est au pub le
arriver et vont continuer à arriver pour
plus je sais qu'on a toujours besoin et
et qui la ferait l'invité à l'émission
dressait contre
beaucoup dans les tweets de d'amateurs
de centre et sa exerçait exacerbée
du démon blond qui fait ce qu'il veut
rock et on part des dégrés commandes il
ce pansement la tour 4 mois il y avait
fait jouer un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
vous d'abord pour le goff hier qu'il
et on l'a beaucoup dit depuis ce matin
famille lafleur
sa retraite parce qu'ils désabusés parce
un succès story incroyable c'est une
pas sur un piédestal mais au même niveau
facture qui a dit manger avec la fleur
c'est pas un mythe l'appui on va parler
leurs enfants et où les gens étaient
souvenir en terminant que vous garderez
dans le métier pour rappeler toute
rêves
derrière maurice richard comme ses deux
lafleur il les appelait personnellement
rencontres une fois dans ma vie j'ai
on sent qu'on est touché et on est
alesi je vous écoute
je pense était mon premier joueur favori
sur un trop fort en vue
que perdre bon allez gens qui se
cancer du poumon on le savait malade ça
revenu en 64 eur 75 avec une saison
que moi par beaucoup est encore très
pendant qu'on attendait ces gens là tout
vous étirer le jour de la retraite guy
améliorer il envoie l'afp jacques strub
ce savoir sa relation avec
talentueux
parle depuis ce matin que vous avez
endroit où ils viennent c'est devant bon
qui viennent voir ce lieu qui viennent
c'est un gros morceau c'est un joueur
matin car tu quand j'ai appris la
toujours un effort il chercher à
quand il raconte le petit déjeuner vous
que les gens nous suivent pour les plus
raconte jean françois qui a fait un
parfois habillé avec un chandail numéro
proie au doute et je pense que c'est
d'amis il est trop tôt j'ai encore des
et il y avait et élégant avec là c'est
76 il aurait été la cible de menaces
alex boissonneault bonsoir bonjour à
et bien il y avait on savait que j'avais
il passe de ses rêves on le voit il est
québec et finalement chez les remparts
ovationné longuement lors de la période
la chimio deux jours avant ou après
aujourd'hui j'étais
vraiment parce qu'il tenait son groupe
parlementaire de québec solidaire qui
beau comme image 193
à 20 heures ce soir j'ai beaucoup souri
pour permettre aux malades
du matin et moi je suis là en attente et
parce que les gens disaient qu'ils
sur la patinoire avec sa crinière de
dernières semaines si que ma mère quand
arrivé quand vous avez commencé à jouer
des savoirs celui de jean notât maison
petit rêve à moi pour aider déjà ma
je pense que devant on doit tous avoir
golos ce dévoué à la cause à quelques
de guy lafleur ben écoute sérieusement
autre issue mais de toute façon ils
c'est pas juste le talent qui fait les
plus de 50 bus trois trophées art ross
depuis ce matin qu'ils vont tous dans la
rendre un hommage à monsieur lafleur
est là pas de varier de choses comme ça
des déclarations d'amour à son endroit
bonjour à guy et on le dit il dépasse
les bras croisés sont pas dans une gorge
joueur de hockey mais ces données ces
puis
qu'ils comptent pas des vertus il est
fortement ce matin c'est une grande
peut-être cette situation de mai il
il y avait tout le monde connaissait
vraiment triste parce qu'on savait se
demandent est ce que c'est le plus grand
l'importance qu'elle vit la flore pour
c'était vous réjean tremblay en 84 quand
surtout fier de pouvoir dire qu'on a
allait faire des tours d'hélicoptère à
c'est dur à imaginer qu'un des jardins
fleur en arrache particulièrement en
histoire d'un jeune homme qui promenait
soit c'est un menteur où il est décédé
laquelle on avait perdu seulement huit
le monde qui a un certain âge tout le
l'organisation du club
à des gens qui m'ont nous rappeler entre
prédécesseurs
de look et de politiciens aussi
et vous parlez du colisée de québec
il a quitté
sa statue qui est devant l'hôtel de
exceptionnelle à la hauteur des attentes
chez nous sans les 15
que sur lequel vous avez travaillé il ya
forum parce qu'ils n'avaient plus accès
activités
laflamme ça s'est fait vite - il avait
la joie c'était quand même assez
s'améliorer
dit c'est pas compliqué guy lafleur
guy lafleur avait du charisme il met
jeunes y a il ya donné une entrevue je
était c'est dur de moins performé vous
pendant 5 me de
nouvelle ça nous a tous attristés puis
aux kinks donc qu'ils sont meilleurs et
d'instinct c'est un joueur qui avec son
qui je veux pas l'arrière puis
est un grand fan de rock et aussi et qui
où il battra tous les records dont une
bien clément mais j'avais une coupe de
comprendre et confirmés et voir
de supporteurs avec une pointe et une
là c'était le dernier des grands là vous
guy lafleur aura été le plus grand de sa
moi je connais quand même assez bien
d'échauffement laplaud fera exploser le
l'aviez berges il
québec jours
perdu est déboussolé exactement puis
qui incarnent des valeurs
contact avec les gens c'est ce disent on
j'annonçais décision
article sur un repli défensif plus que
merci beaucoup claudiennes à thurso en
le pointage jean-françois on à serge
beaucoup à aller voir le passé puis
soi l'establishement ne soit lésé les
qu'il a flers pointe comme ça et je
rivés à la télévision on voyait la fleur
la société québécoise pas seulement pour
du train prend 3 watts sur la il y avait
matchs dont on dit que c'était la
cette fois et pourra prendre sa retraite
surtout une phrase là on a trouvé on a
y est d'ailleurs c'est très proches dont
d'enlèvement puis vous l'aurait dit
sont avec le peuple avec les spectateurs
grandeur d'âme c'est un homme très
leurs jouets qui lui a été content de
région à mon compte et alors quel beau
vous étiez assistant entraîneur à
elle était jeune a gardé guy lafleur pis
tout le monde c'est ça aussi
humain on sort
il était d'une force d'énergie d'eau qui
carrières de guy lafleur le plus
parlez moi du joueur qu'est ce qui fait
le milieu modeste d'un village
grand est question dans le fond sont pas
avec lui
des rêves puis si c'est ce qui est
c'est vrai que le traité soit de l'est
je pense que pour arriver là ça parlait
en profonde réflexion il le sait qui
accepté puis ensuite guy lafleur décide
damnés
10 du canadien de montréal qui ont
puis c'est une personne qui était du
ces gens là certains matchs bref un guy
ville il ya des gens qui viennent y
disais tantôt c'est quand il peut n'y a
monsieur legault qui a déjà twitté va
puis suis là depuis environ neuf heures
de rock qui ce matin notamment une
impressionnant victimes des mais il
bonnes années c'est là qu'il opte vous
remis au meilleur marqueur du trophée
vu un peu pour ça fait en septembre
années il y en avoir avec canadien
avait pris il avait marqué 30 buts la
avez dû constater c'est d'une part
connus ces personnages
la cage des rencontres j'ai passé une
10 est très malade et a continué de
secondes à sa cause a nui à sexuelle la
la gauche qui au niveau de la capacité
cheveux c'est mon âme akimov aux
un vrai cessez le feu
sent mieux mais honnêtement
bougé la génération où ils m'ont fait
aussi sa relation je veux revenir sur sa
même si on s'y attendait
saison de 130 bus en plus de mener son
disiez aussi ce matin faut pas se faire
histoire
le prix d'août c'est toujours la vérité
monde une anecdote concernant guy
paul
c'est le canadien de montréal il raconte
d'installer des podcasts sur fouquet
comme ça
le canadien de montréal a réagi tout
tout qu'est ce que tu peux sur la glace
puis
meilleure saison de l'histoire de la
les fans de hockey mais pour la
perte pour le monde du sport il pauvres
pense ce journal de montréal en dix ans
simple et très gentil il se prenait
savard en ligne qu'on va aller voir mais
des archives qu'on n'a jamais vus et les
que bon l'hélicoptère survolait ici la
en retour le canadien se contente sans
vous disiez ce qu'on dit depuis ce matin
couverts serge savard et il allait il a
forum comme à ses belles années avec une
on a tout a eu un bon contact puisse
j'entend parler des anciens des
qui dominait la lnh avec autant de
lepa veulent pas tout le monde
génération faut jamais oublier que joe
un clin d'oeil d'un peuple et il a subi
s'est exprimé en ces termes devant les
outaouais merci beaucoup il ya eu
avec le sentiment d'avoir complété son
renfiler les patins et de jouer puis il
de la force de l'homme la résilience de
canadiens qui est temps de faire est
puis s'était pas juste passé le joueur
juste à vous pour que personne le sache
l'histoire du canadien au temple de la
d'autre part est ce que vous vous ça
médecins que
talent était capable de jouer 200 pieds
deux soient les pépins soit devant des
était une douce léthargie moi je tâte
responsables de ce jeudi tout le monde
son fils ont dit ce matin très tôt il ya
mère quand elle était jeune a gardé guy
et c'est ça c'est la famille lafleur
parler à 14 heures il serait étonnant
il y avait des c y et à pâte à choux
s'échapper très bien merci beaucoup très
rencontre pour la deuxième fois je
pas que ça dans la zone avec plein de
qu'ils étaient si explosif qui était si
même direction
je pense que c'était là la belle des
journée complète à parce que peut-être
on perd un grand homme je suis vraiment
était très accessible
collectivité québécoise donc pour
rêver et quand je joue au parc qui ont
hart décerné au joueur par excellence un
actuellement qui reçoivent un très
québec la hauteur
son sport bien sûr mais parlons de
de récupération c'était le plus en forme
déposer des fleurs des bâtons de hockey
malheureusement il le sait qu'il est
guy lafleur c'est un grand joueur
un petit mot dans les années soixante
et variées par ce qui est dit j'ai parlé
tout le monde à l'ail c'est un vrai
maltraité on ne traite pas la hauteur de
lafleur géant qui nous a quittés
et on a vu plusieurs partisans se réunir
le passé alors je convaincu que ça vaut
et puis il semblait bien je dis
saison précédant sa première retraite
ça monsieur carrez à sochaux avant
histoires puis comme j'écoute rend
trouvé une faille d'un café est la seule
personne
prenez un taxi à lesmont price à ces
est parti six jeunes lina saneh le monde
l'adorent et voudrait le garder lafleur
sports jose pour montrer ses photos da
pour le canada
important dans vie c'est d'aller au bout
grands joueurs marquez leur sport les
montréal dont vous l'avez vous avez
il n'y a jamais eu peur de dire ce
lafleur
vrai que j'ai parlé dit lui il nous
témoigné des rencontres qu'ils ont fait
totalement d'autres personnes puis tout
c'est la vérité quand une seule n'a pas
pas de faire comme vous dites mais ça
d'illusions là c'est le dernier de ces
il y en a trois dans la peau 8 il y en a
relation avec les fans c'est bertrand
performance de deux vit une passe les
faire ça alors moi si tu tapes
son courage de cette profonde
c'était quand même assez leur
comme de mizani juste à l'unil lorsque
quelqu'un qui prend sa retraite puis ils
venu se recueillir devant le numéro 10
rien enlever à ségalas label gold
lafleur pis on a tout a eu un bon
commence à jaser avec lui et a le temps
beaucoup beaucoup de réactions depuis ce
c'est un gars qui est qui est ma surface
jacques lemaire après 19 matches n'a que
ligue guy lafleur était le meilleur
qui font partie du peuple alors monsieur
de manille 0 mais
oeuvre
mauvais
gens vont voilà c'est ce soir le 20h le
les amis sont un peu surpris à la fois
ya eu new york du québec avec bergeron
équipe à la coupe memorial
je me disais qu'il a fait en mairie de
une anecdote puis en même temps il
jamais pronos puis je pensais depuis le
municipalité je suis devant la statue
que ce qu'elle fait pour l'euro qui
et ne pas être dans une tour d'ivoire et
renommée voici quelques commentaires
était trop comparable ici aussi bien le
support gens mais vous vous avez joué
bien de la peine il donnait il donnait
condamné malheureusement parce ce cancer
durant la finale de la coupe stanley ce
c'était un peu ça aussi il ya deux pense
des passes à la fleur la fleur qu'on met
et je pense que cette perspective comme
récemment giuly une partie donc du
peut-être encore espoir que tu es pour
préféré à mon père mais c'est parce que
donc c'était pas un joueur fini il l'a
raymond célèbre chronique al kindi guy
françois legault c'est très clair que
connu sa dernière année de très près vos
qu'il ya pas tout un dispositif qu'ils
intéressant on va là tu reçois en retour
aujourd'hui jean françois poirier vous
dix il a été le meilleur joueur pendant
vous a étonné qu'ils en avaient encore
à près de marquer des buts et gagner les
compte que voir ces postes l'hôtel st
détermination et ça je pense qu'on doit
idoles marre que les peuples le québec
de nos choses
de question qu'ils reviennent avec les
défis il était fort et on est on aimait
il n'y avait rien fait poser deux autres
matin est ce une avalanche de réactions
vitesse puis leur cesser les cheveux
un bel homme
d'hockey on appréciait beaucoup la
grande superstar
regardait droit dans les yeux ils
autour de la statue de guy lafleur venir
capable c'est la fleur le centre et
était un exode fournier des coupes
s'il y en a qui l'ont pas fait la preuve
inquiétude qui a eu il a chambré pour
contact puisse totalement de votre
yeux il y allait aller rechercher le
avec lui dans la dernière période dont
labrosse ya et rue fortin qui joueront
québécois
mais je veux bien une anecdote de
et puis guy est un colloque
pas pareil mais non moins yayi sa
pas un mythe il avait un coeur
très bon
clough merci beaucoup de ce témoignage
jean béliveau est alors dans l'entourage
impressionne autant que durèrent sa
athlète exceptionnel
canadiens gagnent le match mais la fleur
un soulagement ou aux accompagnants ce
avec guy lafleur et ce qui revient le
patrice qu'on a recueilli pour vous ici
et was
mais c'est lui qui va décider de rejouer
de problème mr aulas d'après midi à
géants qui nous quitte dernier des
de prolonger de
s'adresse à ses joueurs il s'adresse aux
février au faut pas oublier qui est
spectaculaire le voir là un intérêt de
que ses origines venait de là aussi au
dedans pour rejouer plusieurs années
qu'ils pensent et puis
des bons souvenirs de lui
était bon de voir le père raconter à son
les paquets la présence qui a vu le clip
bases à nice et qui pleure connaissait
guy lafleur était l'idole d'un peuple
pour mettre ça de côté de
peut-être une ovation à chacun des
qu'on a érigé ici devant l'hôtel de
un clip descoings or c'est un l'a fait
que vous entendez oui c'est un soin
puis ça a été des moments quand même
s'est rendu par la suite mais moi j'ai
joueur de cette formation là c'était lui
du peuple québécois et qui a toujours
revenir mais par la suite une de
personne puis tout le monde dit pire on
soient enseignants puis il ya des
excellence des séries éliminatoires et
souvent à d'autres des cadeaux qu'ils
faut s'amuser
il ya un côté champions qui arrive est
programment à peu près pour prendre sa
dans le vent c'est les séries il prenait
à peu près un mois et légumes si
autant de succès c'était une source
nature sous la ville de naissance de
spire m'en donner c'était aussi clair
on vous a monté une petite minute de
sol est excellente et on perd un grand
une bonne période c'est le meilleur
communiqué de gharib porte pardon de
comme ça d'un faux nez que ça quoi ça
sans rappeler un moment difficile il ya
avec guy lafleur tatoué sur le coeur
ben oui moi je suis arrivé je tu
municipalité tout le monde aimait guy
joueur et il y avait beaucoup de guy
prouvé lorsqu'il est revenu quelques
pouvaient avoir plein de vedettes autour
quelqu'un qui a été une super vedette
gall il y avait de la drive factice pas
stanley c'est le fait que j'étais
il n'y en aura plus comme ça au rang de
dans votre documentaire vous avez
régulateur j'étais à rome je m'en allais
faire nous soit réinscrit on se couche
épouvantable mais il veut continuer
soit la deuxième étoile de public comblé
de comprendre à quelque part que sans
maquillage josé je crois me dit mon job
avez travaillé sur un documentaire qui
1959 qui avait butin c'est un petit plus
ça s'appelait
voilà lycées ça va se poursuivre comme
exceptionnelle des capacités pulmonaires
porter des gerbes de fleurs notamment je
right de ces jeunes le 10 juin 1971 au
silence bien entendu aussi des
rassembleur mesdames et messieurs ratez
voir quelqu'un comme ça qui traversent
aujourd'hui en a beaucoup qui vont faire
que je t'avoue prendre la tête
est bon mais on connaît l'histoire est
jamais avec le canadien et comme de fait
comme jeudi la chance de jouer avec guy
vraiment grande pour l'entreprise et la
électrisant quand on ya compté les deux
parler de son panache sur la glace de
c'est lui qui des fois dans un avion
ça demandera encore plus pour moi le
beaucoup de lui ben écoute est-ce qu'on
cause par la suite mais sa cause c'était
aussi un grand fan de rock et comment
plus jeunes eddy cail marquait pas la
le joueur offensif la grande vedette de
arrivé je vous
plus souvent c'est sa générosité son
téléphone il va encore noyé je reviens
plus tard que la l1 2 puis les nordiques
surtout quatre coupes stanley d'affilée
mohicans
l'adolescence on va dire puis c'est avec
tétouan 3par et moi j'ai un singe mais
nous sommes tous en deuil aujourd'hui
beaucoup de succès n'est gagné quatre
un guy lafleur qui n'était pas juste
va toujours avoir des bons souvenirs de
immense de fierté d'ailleurs on aura
discussions au moment où l'on se parle
lafleur se rendait pas compte à quel
dont une des années que c'était plus
fils la légende qui a été dit la flore
vraiment sortis des archives que j'avais
moi même à 50 jours à l'intelligence et
au cours des années suivantes on le
deux
retraite en a fait un mort un malheureux
nombreux traitements et le traitement
avaient reçus de mehdi mort tac un essor
j'étais bon je veux pas être comparé aux
enfants style qui vaut un âge d'or qui
fanfare justement il demeurait chiens
en hall et les sentiments des émotions à
on à madame 18 ans mépris
compteur chez le canadien mais bien sûr
monsieur lafleur en outaouais bien sûr
honnêtement ça me flatte gasté ce matin
il faut toujours gagner le plus possible
mal à rentrer dans une petite boîte non
sera présenté ce soir à rdi vous vous
ville elle a été émis en place ici en
lafleur et de toute sa carrière dans
le coma d'un pack que qu'est-ce qui lé
lui
assurément famille patrie il ya eu trois
cérémonies quelque chose d'un peu plus
discussions avec la famille parce qu'on
journalistes qui viennent parler à
que ça on était à vancouver on
bus à montréal et est revenue jouer la
décès parce qu'à la fin ça a été
c'est soit la situation le étaient
coupes stanley
pas juste avec les anciens mais
mes condoléances à sa famille et à ses
celui pour qui ça allait toujours dit et
une image les les cheveux blonds qui lui
j'avais gagné un langage adapté aux
jawf mohcine qui a écrit donc guy
tellement gentille ont parlé de choses
kozah chimio exige faudra être prudent
pub on n'est rien il sent le monde on
avec courage toujours assumé toutes les
arrivais à 84 du programme olympique et
elle était capable quand même d'offrir
pas ça parce que moi j'avais quand même
d'abord toujours l'espoir
ici mis notre passé si la deuxième était
héros
toute la fierté que tiraient les
patrick roy serge savard à qui on a
peux vous montrer derrière et à
vers un puit joyet il y avait deux
de l'autre côté c'est pour vous ça
vous vivez ce à ce moment là mais inclut
délai les respectera à moudre
était aussi douloureux que la malade j
point les créer du bonheur autour de lui
veille il m'a dit au gardien auxiliaire
ça on ira québec dans quelques minutes
voir nos jeunes me rappelle mon iphone
lui j'ai commencé à regarder leur quête
non seulement pour les amateurs du
se soit au lieu d'un moment de silence
je ne suis pas d'avoir entendu je m'en
jamais vu de ma vie et on le on entre
quelques années mais est ce le côtoyer
parlait droit dans les yeux et qui la
ils ont peu joué ensemble c'est dommage
verra souvent représenté une canadienne
complet de décolleté ça rappelle
côté terre à terre le temps qu'il
sept à cette fougue là l'expression être
tout de même assez tard et puis le la
à faire le bien quoi autour de lui a
l'entente l'occasion d'entendre
difficile mais quand même il restait il
laissé aux termine dernier et le
des gars comme steve shutt la robinson
son époque et en plus qui le meilleur
nationaux qui se forme dans le tissu
vous après midi en cornouailles est avec
veut respecter la file les volontés de
des producteurs qui doivent s'assurer
à tout autre chose
n'ont semble pas donner du tout m'a pas
la porte le pays tu voyais logement je
jean tremblay d'abord bonjour
dis la fleur du ipad il accueille avait
et d'autres mais moi j'étais avec mario
l'organisation du canadien de montréal
plat pour moi servait magath si vous
extrêmement difficile
a pas de ces gens là évidemment mais on
c'est le premier message que j'ai reçu
interdisait tri on le décalage horaire
première fois mon rien c'est quand même
lendemain de la retraite de jean
dès le 16 février suivant le canadien
la belle superbe manoeuvre très
québécois le voir comme ça marquer des
2013 puis je vous inviter à regarder les
fleur de peau comme on dit à guy lafleur
mais c'est pas de glisser peu de gens de
toutes ces personnes qui veulent nous
et mais c'était tel entrain de bain dans
trader mais j'avais écrit une couple de
toutes mes questions présentées des
n'est rien même avec les journalistes
davantage le commentaire de la part de
c'est guy la france et le canada
je terminerai en citant son hématome au
saisons au cours desquelles il a marqué
si je n'ai pas mal de choses en
avec moi puis on m'a dit je te déranger
êtes retremper dans la vie de ce
à cette époque les joueurs du canadien
vous avez pu parler à pas mal de monde
lafleur a connu une carrière
moins de 12 ans et demi avec pierre
proches et c'est intéressant parce que
est lui plus jeune je regardais pas ça
donc il y avait décidé après les failles
un niveau de jeu quand même intéressant
solenelle qu'ils soient organisés à son
déclarations la fête est toujours livré
en hélicoptère où il a été acheté un
canadien les québécois mais partout au
france et sos d'un groupe proche de c2c
si vous vous rappelez dans ces années-là
laissé sur le cul je me rappelle la
guy lafleur le super héros guy lafleur
pays d origine ce sont d'excellents
de diminuer la force de visionner ces
tire lui dit me morice
même s'il ne s'est jamais gêné pour
nous monsieur cournoyer vous avez joué
à g j'ai eu l'occasion de diriger l'île
voie que cela que la poulie basque à
la famille s'il doit y avoir des
prenait pour discuter avec les amateurs
qui a déroulé un des tapis rouges autour
par les années les années qui ont suivi
parlé et ronald corey
sait mettre les joueurs jeunes joueurs
de rentrer plus tôt le lendemain puis
je souligne que le premier ministre du
houle a ajouté l'elysée ouais mais ce
des noces à la caisse tué une femme
lemieux est vraiment bien j'ai dit guy
france guy lafleur je croise les gens
neige je m'en fous rires au bout de la
dans mon lit ce matin d'un ami ça fait
pee wee faye a grandi avec les remparts
intégrante de nos vies entre autres la
qui soufflait l'enlever avec son patin
quelque chose aux comptes et de but
parce qu'elle était initialement rester
dire à quel point il était l'idole de
êtes vous en servez voici qui est il là
prévision des missions mais il ya des
lieux sa carrière alors guy lafleur des
cancer foudroyant vers la fin il est
claudine
ce qu'on ferait de décor ça rappelle
à ce qu'on trouve une solution quel que
oui mais gérable mais la première fois
dépassé son nombre de bus par exemple
rencontre avec lui au restaurant au
beaucoup de souvenirs j'ai vu que
canadien à la séance de repêchage sam
86 je parle il y avait eu une fusillade
colloque ce matin qu'ils disaient qu'ils
m'en raconter le but de thil il y avait
puis me raconter une anecdote un jour
sur le bout de son siège c'est ça quand
que
canada on connaissait ce joueur qui
des leaders des différentes formations
beaucoup de taizé à pied et m'baye
bouchard et le sound et jésus guy
étonné du tout parce que on sentait que
ces messages on savait que ça n'allait
c'était ce que tous les gens de mer
plusieurs la fin de sa carrière repli
restait le démon blond pareil
donné les messages que lui croit
terrain de baseball
un peu le fond sa pensée un peu comme un
mario trably tout ces joueurs là
gars pour moi dans l'organisation du
j'ai commencé avec guy lafleur puis je
funérailles nationales discussions aussi
buts importants quelque chose de plus
mes joueurs pour serge pugeault mais on
peut aussi apprécier ce qui fait depuis
dorure en faire à la fin de la pression
contre patrick roy les
montréal c'était tête td td
sociologique d'une société et qui peu
pieds en fait de guy lafleur ici c'est
images là on attendait on veut qu on les
choses j'avais jamais vu que j'ai vu
devant la maison l'équipe f1 du côté air
les rangs du canadien savait pas
j'ai voulu faire un retour au jeu
il est toujours demeuré simple
de 71 à 119 avec monsieur lafleur toutes
et d'aider les nordiques par la suite
organise une cérémonie qui lui rend
coeur comme sa fille donc il ya fait
oui plusieurs personnes qui nous content
une vingtaine royer à droite il y avait
d'arrêter les traitements et guy c'était
terre va faire ça en quatre minutes et
là j'aurai besoin d'une histoire
en avant l'huile ils y ont vu file mais
à montréal qui était souvent au centre
l'entrevue pendant deux heures puis
ont besoin de l'extérieur d'extérioriser
et montréal
de hockey de partout québec il ya même
savoir on voyait des images tout à
personnage là qui est plus grande nature
quelque chose ça nous a botté le cul
déjà déjà c'est une évidence et il ya
antoine bertschy puis mario les murs et
j'anime bord des voies d eau sera à
desquelles il a marqué 50 bus et plus il
dans sa bulle on le comprend on comprend
de ses fans et combien de jeunes
combien il faut qu'on le vu le descende
conférence de presse en réaction à cette
québec va tenir un point de presse à 14h
de la statue installée quelques
ont été marqués à l'hôpital par sa
pas dans la deuxième portion de 70 il
intelligente grave et ce grâce que parce
il y avait une autorité une confiance
histoires comme ça on en deux temps mais
qu'il sent bon que les gens ici en ont
allait tirer 200 rondelle s'il fallait
tout à l'heure je vous ai fait un temps
important de donner au monde sébastien
difficiles comme maurice richard avant
mienne puis ah oui et guay cc spécial
dans votre dans votre montage des
superbe super vedette le sait le premier
pourquoi
puis données des cartes ac/dc photo
canadien et trois gars il ya eu le droit
pollock se pointer à la tribune et
j'allais là à reno qui tatouent jeunes
sont souvent à ces jeunes parfois trop
centre bell ils se pointent leur donc
j'avais quelqu'un à ottawa qui atteint
qui a inspiré des générations et des
à l'aéroport de rome chaque mois je les
ça pour nous à demeurer compétitifs en
était vu comme un marqueur exceptionnel
ses 6 et quand je suis à chaque fois que
dessus c'est très généreux un gars qui
installer régulièrement ma part jamais
d'un verre et puis tout acabit mais
beaucoup de souvenirs j'ai vu que
de ses contemporains avec ils étaient
gens étaient contents pour lui
n'avait quand ils incitent de pénalité
de québec alors et puis je me souviens
d'un autre os x les world games
parce que lui et veut pas d'un de
bell mais il y avait toujours il y avait
guy était malheureux avec ce qui se
manpower
le gymnase je pense pas qu'il n'apparaît
que seulement son chandail des rares qui
nous sommes amusés à faire un joke agile
et l'aurait la transmission il ya eu un
accessible et près des partisans et des
rex 4 400 tr knight et le monde les gens
plus grand que nature on réalise en
après à fin d'entrevue j'étais avec ma
auraient pu été de dire on est on sait
suis resté guide à flacey générosité
l'heure des défilés de la coupe stanley
vraiment des anecdotes où ils ont côtoyé
a voulu que termine topec canadien il
générosité par sa résilience par son
barrières autour envoie également les
soit le problème
directement au sol c'est le maire de
pour vous qu'est ce tu es la présence de
il y avait jacques lemaire alors je
moi j'ai faim
avait le lendemain c'était que beauvais
athlètes et les entraîneurs avec lamari
intéressant spontanée et là il y avait
on aura les détails sûrement
sous le coude le flanc droit puis marqué
je devais repêché ce beau dors plus je
à quelques du baroudeur qui nous a
un véhicule un mois je regarde ce petit
même qu'il ya certaines personnes qui
et électrisante séquence voyait
peine avec une perf mais la face parker
petit prince il m'avait dit bouge pas
il ya des habous laisse également
des gens qui m'ont dit on a vu des
aussi ça ressemble à un homme en
peut-être l'extrait qui nous a tous mis
filles et tous voyaient qui était
ses démons aussi parfois qu'ils sont ce
saint-françois vous êtes autant de la
est le meilleur joueur au monde
amis d'ailleurs gilles villeneuve était
nationale vont savoir qu'est ce qui va
a inscrit presque 100 points de plus que
quoi il ya quarante ans que cette salle
puis tout le bénin comme il s'est levé
beaucoup de gens nous ont dit être
qu'il ya essayé jean-françois quelques
ya deux autres joueurs de harkis qui ont
il est vrai qu'on aime ce qu'il dit
du cancer chez lui très enfants de guy
le un peu le destin d'un peuple en même
aujourd'hui on est là on peut pas notre
auprès des signatures rouge est
importe la classe sociale peu importe le
puis des domaines festif de démontrer
qu'est-ce qui fait lorsque vient le
nos sympathies monsieur cournoyer on le
joie de l'histoire la collecte six
pas une mauvaise voiture mais quand ça
un joueur de l'équipe
besoin de ce moment de recueillement ce
10 ans guy lafleur comme the six lui ça
jeunes d'âge et puis elles se sont très
avait traversé fn ça veut dire tout le
plains d'avion à rome pour manas lé un
sait que terrible mais qu'ils viennent
quitté en 2000
et c'est ce qui est important ce point
d'une anecdote à thurso tout jeune le
j'allais la reno puis tu as tout jeune
regardant ces images là c'est une télé
science brûler on a demandé
jeune pour avoir connu les belles années
jamais complètement abasourdi qu'est ce
public s'exciter automatiquement parce
aller-retour casemate 2000 il y avait
vraiment où est l'eau il y avait
dernièrement depuis depuis décembre il y
amateurs de hockey au québec au canada
aimait rire aussi c'était comique et
fleurs qui ont été déposées bien sûr on
jeu libre par en dedans à 15h
à montréal vous aviez vu des images vous
combien de jeunes ont joué sur la
pour se remettre dedans pour un turc au
nécessaire depuis ce matin mais
les remparts de québec en avait besoin
se passer à partir de maintenant la mise
courage par ses qualités du main à
pense qu'au début bon même mieux donner
que les changements font partie de
jamais levé un poids de cynisme
générations de québécois guy lafleur qui
que les deux samoa d'une semaine à
eu droit à des funérailles nationales
fois dans l'entrevue jeu c'est richard
temps de prendre la parole et dit temps
rénover renommée pardon à toronto
thurso qui me dit bon avant
profondément attristé on sent que c'est
directement leurs héros et une anecdote
papier je le dis depuis ce matin moi
t'aiment après il y avait beaucoup de
passait dans se tenait la première main
assurément après un dur débuts avec le
je lève quand je l'avais mentionné le
saisons de suite avec au moins 5 a pu et
le motton dans la gorge quelques mois
simagrées de
vont jusqu'à dire bon qu'avec sa mort
voitures de policiers l'homme avait il
toujours du talent c'est jean béliveau
il ya eu le gentilhomme monsieur jean
passage de relais et la passion qui
enfants de 9-10 ans j'ai envie pendant
lafleur il s'approche de la floride une
répété qu'il leur a contré d'abord avec
mario lemieux
au jeu m'a pour moi mais il n'y a pas un
après plus de trois ans jouit des matchs
revenu peu importe où on est au québec
fais ta cabane à terre suite à ce
souffrances qu'on a fait depuis un an un
eu je payais comme sujettes à l eau quoi
notre note vedette c'est lui qui fait la
dépression lorsqu'ils quittent le
moi ça me fait énormément plaisir de
années parce qu'on lui disait n'a pas de
le début de cette façon là avec qui je
monsieur bush à qui va me couche à
comme ceux nous rappeler notre collègue
temps aussi lucky santé fier de le voir
double clic et en suisse les niveaux et
avait annoncé un peu plus tard ce qui va
les grandes années dit la flanc avec les
fille et tu voyais qu'ils étaient
c'est que t'as vrai qu'en qu'elle m'en
et à travers le monde durant sa carrière
ou demander le sa présence
but est admiré par une photo avec un
qu'on impose qu'ils y ils étaient très
en berne du drapeau combien de jours
lecteur par benzarti qu'avaient mes
s'attend à ce qu'ils en aient davantage
monde pouvait l'aborder c'était un
passepont c'est quand je n'ai jamais vu
travers la maladie à travers les
quel point on avait beaucoup
disons stop aux tapas une grande grande
presse je trudeau va parler monsieur
carrément dans notre j'ai appris la
l'inauguration de la statue bien entendu
d'adolescents depuis tellement madame
d'arrêt
réalité c'est la première téléréalité
aviez la coupe et lui était juste
qu'on savait il se fait à l'espace et
fait ça va à peu près 1 9 minutes
floch nord c'était un vrai québécois et
est le dernier de cette tendre l'un de
puis même total que moi j'ai dans ma
fédé va pas toujours le timing dans ses
grande franchise et je pense que c'est
qu'ils puissent transmettre ses
l'occasion de le rencontrer c'est à
guy lafleur avait toujours du temps pour
arrive à sa nounou pas mal moi jamais
véritablement un deuil pour non
faisait partie de la société
d'octobre dernier car monsieur lafleur
mick ça représente l'excellence je
une partie de l'homme presque de thurso
que fait guy lafleur vous voulez vous
passer la zone neutre sam la barre puis
prochain match il allait marquer quand
peut-être le deuxième jeu de puissance
boréal matin qu'un journal à montréal la
beaucoup de compagnons toujours qu'avec
méta 3,4 bio est il si les canadiens
vraiment d'où il y avait beaucoup de
désir de toujours en faire plus c'est
juge las sur moi puisqu'elle ya vu que
canadien martin je crois parce que leur
bien entendus tout l'état parfums
de son dernier but
dit depuis tout à l'heure oui on le sait
demande 'est-ce que tu suis fière elle
le centre le centre de guy la place
donné que deux stars de l'équipe de
l'autre de vendredi les deux de cancer
sébastien bovet maurice richard en 2000
nationale à cette époque était marcel
comme s'il allait passer à qu'il devrait
bon sens pour des raisons sécuritaires
dans les heures à venir on a même
d'admiration pour la
monde ici il faut dire que l'on m'a dit
être fait dans la municipalité de thurso
j'ai eu j'ai connu le meilleur des deux
premier rang de la séance de repêchage
son père il ya des photos avec pierre
leur imposer une coupe des questions
une demi heure avec guy lafleur alors
différence et puis celui qu'on suivait
les fans
au profit d'oeuvres caritatives avec
rappellera sûrement pour mémoire de deux
béliveau est
an je vous dirais je passe au travers
il ya été moi j'aime personnellement
avait moins de réponse j'ai eu texto
toronto oh mais porical donne alors
derrière vous et ils vous tenait par le
guy lafleur ça commence dans les années
que j'arrive à dire programme j'ai juste
donc c'est tout ce qui est en train
sa glande à sa force cei et à pau cqp
canadiens mais tous ont souligné le fait
monsieur qui pouvaient du rosé képi ce
qui nous ont marqués entre autres c'est
fait un point des coupes stanley les
s'est
on lui en a parlé de cette statue
c'était tout de même entre emilie y
immenses défis qui le véhicule dans les
voit et la flore lui en fin de semaine
de voir guy lafleur les rendre fiers
au lieu du premier jeu depuis sa charge
et nous a permis de vivre de grands
quelque chose tu es un gars comme quand
béliveau l'élégance la fla c'était le
un trait de caractère qui impressionnait
super avec moi alors il l'a invité à
legault prendre la parole à 14 heures si
trop prenant la main trop rapidement et
ne pourrait pas parler l'homme est
je lui avais donné les clés pour qu'ils
dionne donc c'était une domination
ses héros populaire
seulement les amateurs de rock qui met
pas facile à porter non plus pour lui
monsieur legault qui va
un autre show c'est un autre univers
être lettres d'enfants que post boulot
au
de la ligue nationale de hockey jamais
veux pas en arrière puis d'installer des
blagues mais essayez c'est drôle et puis
morceau guy labrouche peut-être ce temps
quand que ça allait arriver ces jours ci
presse et là c'est le seul qui pouvait
repêcher et le canadien devient donc
darribeau aussi il était très attaché la
10 es bon tu que ça passe vite on le
d'être déterminée au moment où l'on se
mais sur la fête sa carrière ce qui a
kg morgane zélande fidji ouest salle
mais le maire et qui lui-même avoue
idylle des saisons de 27 27 27 30 bus
il y aurait aimé le public fait tout ça
était qui tâtonne et apple guy prêts
je te par ce biais des sites passés à la
tout 300-400 cassette de radio-canada
jours la première fois fait que c'était
en tout cas et dans plusieurs endroits
équipe qu'on avait des guides est
d'anciens coéquipiers les convaincus par
ca va vous pour vous en parler 30 but en
il ya s'ils cassent tout ça peut marcher
jean béliveau en 2014 on s'attend à ce
on dit un perfectionniste qui voulait
hockey mais this de dire qu'ils auront
veston pour vous empêcher d'avancer step
montréal et jean béliveau et maurice
les cris des données et à gaza jamais
faisais on parle d'une légende on parle
mondes si j'étais petit jeune qui a été
criant et guy lafleur con on a joué à ça
fait de même à rabat et
je n'ai xénon elle était toujours
il a été il fait partie de l'imaginaire
tout ce qu'on a croisés ici près du
60 on ne sait images du jeune lafleur
plus exposé à un tel
le maire qui nous dit qu'elle pour la
c'est à un gode du peuple un gosse
compagnons disons qu'avec lui depuis que
un mec des vies d'aujourd'hui la vitesse
qui part alors le maire de thurso et que
des soldats et des mitraillettes de ce
beaucoup les québécois d'abord des
une fois que tu maîtrises 3 et forza 4
jeune vie je suis venu match canadien
aux noms recel a été merveilleux le
que sa dépense les générations que ça va
j'ai jamais été archi câble avec lui
moments de fierté collective
du poumon alors vous pouvez vous - faux
qu'ils portent les couleurs des
j'avais évolué au club est arrêté sur 20
beaucoup et puis aussi c'est que ma mère
alice l'offensive
pour ma fête au mois de février on avait
puissent venir s'entraîner très tôt le
que sa phase la phase 2 de 10 g au pot
là on a posé cette question là il s'est
forum à l'époque
hélas s'est fait autour de guy lafleur
exactement mais il devenu certaines
au canada guy lafleur ça fait partie de
là où quelque chose et il a mérité
donc pour françois legault guy lafleur
en voyage et puis je voyais avec mon
trudeau qui allait au forum à l'époque
monsieur lafleur chapelle ardente est ce
il est québécois disent justement tout
l'équipe de guy lafleur grâce à la ruse
mais lui avec vous il y avait encore le
renommée du hockey à toronto
surpoids - guy lafleur c'est mon idole
podcasts sauf guy lafleur serviette
mais que lui demanda pas d'être super
était le fait même ses spectaculaires il
regretté la guette bouche et une
d'échanger avec vous ça donne ça donne
de nous avoir parlé à même d'accueillir
nordiques de québec je m'aventure vers 5
sait pas quand on est jeune mais ça
c'est je dirais que surtout lui puis
offrir et qui a déjà offert à la famille
parle et c'est ce qu'on devrait préciser
l'arrivée d'un joueur junior n'aura
richard guy lafleur la partie de céder
mais
années la patrie selon the sun is ces
33 matchs et devient le démon blond à
très longtemps le casque il le portait
je comprends tout à fait en mesure aussi
poser le titre intéressant oui il est
mais quand même c'est un choc comment
tellement
un de ses amis d'effectuer un retour au
manger avec cuisine et la réaction du
statue qui a été installé ici en 2013
fondé la de refonder la fondation
qu'il a fait arrêter son idole il reçoit
on avait dû trouver avec lui énormément
gagner
handicap mais cette journal fait pas
beaucoup plus loin que seulement des
centre bell ce matin beaucoup nous ont
deux fois là dessus mais j'ai écouté de
voulait que ça continue qui marque le
l'explosion à l'époque last guy lafleur
mettra en lumière août voyez le monde
face à des dangers qu'on ressent nous
est possible sauf que lorsqu'il pense à
tableau grâce à un bon médicament je
matin parce qu'il voulait tellement
disponibles exil je les ai visionné vais
généreux et j'aimerais qu'on regarde
quand elle était jeune a gardé guy
le vrai mal
extrêmement disponible après bon là des
accueilli à brisbane savait que certains
athlètes d'une grande stature comme ça
peuvent performer avec un joueur de
passe vite il était malade donc qu'il
centre-ville de toronto où guy lafleur
dans l'uniforme des nordiques aussi à
d'une personne qui joue un rôle
il n'était pas dans la douceur pour lui
il a été un des plus grands joueurs de
est en fait joueurs que wayne gretzky
élevé à 7,6 au québec j'ai vu quand j'ai
que ce sera au centre bell ce qu'il y en
sur le premier jeu de puissance il a
c'est elle qui l'avait accueilli en
patrice ce qu'on n'oublie pas non plus
envoyé un texto et puis de souhaite
chez lui avec ses soeurs loïs de seul
qui se passait il ya de personne n'a pas
talent pour le faire donc et quand tu es
nouvelle session je disais j'ai
podium piédestal et on disait que guy
je voyais à quai et se passer parce que
que monsieur lafleur puces les rejoins
remettre dans le bain on va se visionner
aussi c'était un moment où sort était
j'ai joué à ça nous a mis en joie ça il
aussi lors de cette conférence de presse
fans de kiki voit un bon joueur à la
menaces mais ce passé des menaces
monsieur merci
sensation de son exemple exigé rien de
centre et une à la veine du coin que
propre génération il nous manque des
rassembla je ne suis pas du tout un
heures avant une marche deux heures
c'est pas par terre les twitter qui
de jeunesse jean-françois vous avez dit
j'ai eu des bonnes discussions avaient
je pense est un gars qui m'a aidé à
vaut rester gravé à jamais dans notre
ce qu'ils pensent et moi j'étais un peu
et des photos avec guy lafleur après une
cru nécessaire le besoin d'organiser une
mis à pleurer mais pleure il sait qu'un
feu travail admirable dans du drapeau
de sam pollock waouh guy giva temps du
les plus gros des gaules
jusqu'à 73 ça c'est le but en finale de
lafleur pis on a tout ay eu un bon
d'avoir vécu c'est normal c'est josée
prénom dommage je suis même beaucoup
qu'ils pouvaient interpellé
charlie que je pense que c'est ce qui
parlé du fait que quand guy lafleur
aura une à québec et une à montréal
beau phénomènes vont qui peut pas y
tout jeunes nantais - sous sol soit 14,5
durant six saisons là enfin le nombre de
des mots mal qu'ils commettaient un
partir de ce moment-là à 75 il a sa part
facile d'abandonner certains moments ça
en servir mais au début des années 80
d'ailleurs et ensuite dire continuer à
24 c 2 buts 3 passes y'a rien qui va
notre imaginaire et ça c'est même des
maurice richard m'a demandé d'être
vos premières réactions monsieur cours
à quel point c'est déjà important dans
même jour dans le salon le camp guise et
y avait une force et une énergie
derrière moi
pas l'impression de travailler parce que
ils ont eu bien entendu des discussions
et et qu'il a fallu aussi devait
pension à québec durant des années
questions
l'avant dernier match de sa carrière son
étions cabane hôtellerie accor s'est
remarqué caressant carbure au lieu de
d'enlèvements qui avait eu pour faire
de nous laisser comme ça mais je pense
des frissons vous entendre voir les
peux l'écrire band comme ça
c'est des gens courageux ouais mais
une place privilégiée avec les remparts
nous lorsqu'on allait on allait les ai
centre de 7,30 le quitter plus tôt 1-1
recevait un prix y ont dévoilé une
maurice richard c'est un peu patrick roy
monsieur qui a une idole dans la vie et
accroché à une personne qui est
saison il marque 29 juillet à ma 60 4
là il séduit il se doit il s'en
d'avoir pris le temps on va faire un
déjà je nage je nage étaient étaient
temps qu'ils ont
pierre bouchard vous l'avez vu la
avec lego qui avait cinq fois qu'il
avant le match la maison peut-être
bon on imagine comme air différent
tout à fait alors voilà comme vous dites
contact puisse totalement d'autres
télévision est quelque chose de plus qui
qu'on le vit au moment où ça se passe
l'organisation du canadien de montréal
c'est ce qui fait que c'était une g gars
une place de choix dans un xzibit tout
personne il était humble non
spectaculaire où il y avait une capacité
qu'il faut pas l'oublier s'il y avait du
président j'ai terminé terminer assez sa
l'establishment ou dénoncer des
mémoire collective évidemment ça tant ce
bonne fight et surtout 3 soin de ta
nous a donc fait rêver je veux vous
garçon de la famille qui devient la
fait que
aller mais il y appelle être bertrand
coupe stanley dans votre documentaire je
catalans lui aussi acheter tu peux pas
julie on réalise pas ce moment là la
premier à le présenter en fouillant dans
avait la rondelle entre les mains on
aurait été facile de se replier sur soi
j'aimais voir ce que ce que je
durant les remparts et il avait invité à
pendant le camp d'entraînement
avec guy lafleur et pour lui c'était
des 5 octobre c'est la journée de la
canadiens d'ailleurs maurice richard
la coupe stanley chicago la première et
lafleur ne voulait pas être plus haut il
images en même temps de ses montées au
avoir la passion du hockey à leurs
dans sa poche de voix après la conquête
sur la façon dont ça va se dérouler
comme ça aussi que j'adorerais guy
but inscrit par son équipe quand il
la sem et tient tête et tu as aimé tu te
travail le peintre
15,2 soit 415 solitude 80
dernier match à montréal il avait marqué
shah
personnes puis tout le monde dit pire on
logiquement vers le soleil est beau avec
maurice richard et de jean béliveau
content pour lui qu'il vienne au jeu et
grandi j'y voyais qu'il a fort à la
dit je te va le but c'est tout à leur
aujourd'hui on peut se rendre proche du
serge savard merci d'être avec nous
affronter des tempêtes on vient d'aller
courageux
c'est fort possible
extraordinaire ambassadeurs de notre
3e simple qu'un premier centre et
part évalue des faces des parias qui
jeune qui quitte à marquer pour moi
rappelle les différentes personnalités
réuni les trois ans et là évidemment j'y
lafleur est invité par les rangers de
est laissée au québec j'ai parlé un peu
affectionne oui dit c'est sûr qu'on
statue à québec on va écouter ça et
cette sorte est pétri ont fait une belle
savait qu elle avant de l'action on
présents avant tout le monde comme il
ensemble une petite biographie de
qui sait le titre c'est de rassembler et
osm atteint déroulé les tapis rouges
jouer au hockey et l'oeil quartier a
et ce que sont les maths oncologue nous
actuellement il ya peut-être mecque des
cette époque là c'était un joueur qui
qui est juste content de rencontrer et
points au 3e rang chez les recrues de la
écouter l'autre groupe c'est super de
parler bien sûr de mike bossy qui décide
décidé de prendre sa retraite il le prie
situations qui qui ne faisaient pas leur
que ça dit sa déclaration à 14h à et
patrice sais que ce sera une allocution
je connais l'histoire désolé tantôt il
monter ça dans une école de rock et le
crois que j'ai vu un petit bout de film
très bons joueurs n'arrivent pas
raymond puis usées envoyé à l'ensemble
journalistes en conférence de presse il
tour à thurso on va retourner à thurso
c'est des négociations etc la famille
de la coupe stanley quand les flyers ont
l'un portant sur ce elle sollicite les
non c'est cet
panache comme juin puis das aviv après
santé et puis c'était les derniers
j'étais je commencé dans le métier ce
grande star de québec on la voit devant
très honnêtement je pensais que je sais
condescendant vers les coéquipiers comme
demandait beaucoup j'ai une anecdote
merci à lee alex oui donc conférence de
être présents lors de cette fameuse
personnes merci beaucoup guy carbonneau
découvrais le guy lafleur dans des
laflamme je me sentais à l'aise avec une
va toujours avoir des bons souvenirs de
vestiaire peut-être une chance d'avoir
mois ce que ce que ce que je retiens
dimanche à 20 heures une cérémonie qui
plus tôt avec dominique anglade parti
apporter les couches sales et mais c'est
savait qu'elle laisse passer quelque
important qu'ils ses pieds se retrouve
chapelle ardente où si on imagine au
trial airlines reliant il s'agit d'un
c'est l'année suivante que guy lafleur
lui parler à quel moment ça fait au mois
jean béliveau guy lafleur si revenue
lever s'est passé avait quelque chose
premier ministre des ministres mais il y
qu'est-ce qui fait monsieur ça va qu'il
filet extraordinaire qui dit aux gens
de 8 à 10 minutes
pulmonaire et cardiaque
que quand il s'est mis à lui des années
sport alors ces mémos donc utilisé par
était capable de faire la différence
dit aujourd'hui c'est l'homme
femme la journée de la femme de patrick
voulait avoir les deux pieds sur terre
qui avait fait toute sa carrière à
les coupes stanley en 77 contre boston
fini de jouer avec québec la région où
chance qu'on a nommé aujourd'hui le
mais ça devrait être le cas et chapelle
gardes à lui le canadien
dans ce sens là éloge de toutes parts
lui
avec pierre trudeau puis la fleur qui
non j'ai pas parlé cette journée là
lnh après marcel dionne et richard
de lui même il a même annoncé d'un jeu
avait la même opinion tu faisais vu un
va tuer tout le monde est au courant de
talent à qui guy lafleur in the heart
ancien défenseur des canadiens
voir claudine en outaouais bien sûr
il ya quelques jours à peine qu'est ce
monsieur lafleur et ensuite on part on a
le monde reconnaît quand on vient au
vie puis j'étais près de lui venir et
lames sont profonds là après 4-5 minutes
télévision c'était une idole comme
qu'un vous entendez depuis ce matin là
avait engagé pour philadelphie et puis
chose le souvenir de ses cheveux blonds
voir démon blond sans revenir en échappe
va retirer son casque pour de bon koné
libéral est pas st-pierre plamondon du
est ce que monsieur cournoyer là
faire la même chose bilan reste richard
ils dit en entrevue à lise payette
vie ont été les deux tout le monde ont
avec lui qui vient de steve shot son
autour de la statue de guy lafleur ici
1959 qui avait buté c'est un petit peu
à guy lafleur dominés ils débordent des
moi je vois pas souvent mais tout de
nécessairement à ce niveau là exactement
c'est le rassembleur des québécois il
une entrevue guy lafleur un peu fou je
brille partent en voiture de montréal et
émissions de télé du tac au tac chez
c'était il ya plus de temps québec on
extraordinaire qu'il était à travers la
étais et d'amateurs très dérangés par ce
une personne qui était qu'il voulait
moment là je me suis dit des fous des
que l'idole s'intéresse à lui et
accident qui allait sûrement arriver
ensuite on parle à la veuve de jean
mais je m'appelle ou une fois le talent
montréal peut-être qu'ils auraient pu
michel bergeron il marque le premier but
sera donc organisée pour les citoyens
directement au sol alors qu'il ne soit
juillet j'ai tu as fait une réflexion
nous avons parlé c'est très apprécié
monsieur bouchard nous rappeler ça il
n'ose lui il déjà là les projets nés y
ya du monde qui me skype et y'a pas de
dans durant laquelle le premier ministre
seul kobe tu vois c'est aller au bout
blond vous en souvenez vous à 75
pour avoir de la difficulté à en parler
temple de la renommée on est carrément
et alors nous avait souhaité bonne fête
que le québec perd avec ces grands
parti québécois
sans arrêt depuis ce matin c'est le
blague ans après la finale contre les
avait quelque chose de spécial d'attaché
affaire dans une cantine mais la donne
martin
ouais ben je comprendrais
petit peu émotif tout à leur verser
auteur du meilleur
parce que l'histoire qui fut maire des
demain léthargie donc tout est tourné
parce que la fois j'ai parlé si
frissons pont avait ressenti en
c'est un peu pour vous moi je vais aller
ardente à 20 alors que le maire de
dans toute la classe politique bien sûr
partie ges contre les secteurs humaines
nous rendait heureux on voit on le
tilikum la mer le disputent aux de
veux quoi 21 22 ans et quand j'arrive
beaucoup d'invités peau lo kèr guy
l'état donc mon traître gens-là ce
thurso le souhaitait où est né guy
c'est moi c'est sûr c'est sur la mémoire
même une traité de la même façon si
que le canadien extraordinaire il s'est
buehrer à ce que vous dites ah non ça se
qui voudront se recueillir ici se
de sa tignasse blonde au vent sur la
on voulait l'intimider donc ça veut
au niveau 6 c'est comme si loin mais ces
béliveau
centre bell je précise en souvenez pour
avoir une bonne attitude équipe dans la
sur l'esplanade du centre bell et si
dans la réplique du vestiaire du
merci au revoir et à la prochaine on va
presse à 14h - et c'est un peu écrit
s'est excusé yasi
sur tout ce que j'ai pu vivre et d'être
s'en vont rencontrer le monsieur dans
pas sur un podium c'est ça vous démontre
denise les publicités
atteindre au niveau de la population
ils ont essayé de nous battre avec des
l'invite à manger avec lui n'existe pas
au niveau des héros justement au niveau
c'était un peu comme ça aussi qu'on le
monsieur corée qui nous a raconté
un moment donné durant la finale il ya
moi je m'abandonne le joueur beaucoup de
petit à l'époque où je jouais puis à la
pensé dans la gazette à montréal avant
mauvais début de saison vie je pense
soucis
de septembre
parterres ce décret dans la ville pillé
yahia 3g allia 3
c'est une grosse perte
des principes qui lafleur avait pris un
communication assez régulièrement avec
voyait dans les défilés ses coéquipiers
niveau artistique au niveau social au
des matchs intra-équipe à trois rivières
arrivait très tôt au forum il se
hommes si grand joueur de hockey on perd
puis au fur et à mesure qu on fuyait
moment là qu'on ne parle la grippe la
premières impressions je le disais au
romantique il était pilote d'hélicoptère
faire ces précisions va donner ces
fidèle partenaire de trio alors au début
concernant guy lafleur ban lui et vice
quelques larmes ça ça vous attriste son
ce qu'on ferait de décolleté ça rappelle
rangers canadiens gagnent puis tous les
tout à fait éloge qui vous savez qu'à
qui se passait qui t il commencé
accordent des entrevues il se prête au
à guy lafleur lorsque son téléphone
associé aux remparts de québec il a
incident la question comment
près du vestiaire guy lafleur est là qu
chambre cette personne qui était
à fond la caisse mais je n'oublierai pas
c'était vraiment plus plus personnel
et
cette année on était deuxième de voir le
et le premier qui est arrivé avec sa
la fin d'une vie est encore un homme
c'était voisin servir frais pendant deux
assistant à ce but là et tantôt un peu
au milieu d'eux jamais dire jamais au
comme ça avec guy lafleur ils en
communiqué la lnh aussi à peu près au
que j'ai de deux guides qui joua pas de
périodes et bon malheureusement puis
canadien autant de le renommer la seule
allèles et que tu fais quoi y'a pas
police une personne de plusieurs
jégo qui l'a
de venir de rares contres et sa sortie
oui avait la parole facile pour déranger
il ya de tout là dedans sincèrement
son salon et par surprise qui la flore
début on le savait que ça s'en venait
percevait dans la municipalité un gars
et le directeur général phil esposito pu
dans le ciel que oui il y aura des
à quel point le personnage était
qu'après il y avait eu un moment qu'il
la production de la fleur stagne un peu
précisions et ensuite on va répondre à
québec s'apprête tout près de chez vous
toujours accessible ces personnes qui
vous venez de voir un amateur qui a
qu'il retire son casque et devient le
mais la flamme la clope bill walker
c'est resté un peu un grand mystère
quelques jours après une deuxième série
lancer sur réception bien renvoyer
pis c'est celle au
vers lui je n'allais pas consentant veut
décès
de redresser le dos de faire face
dernier des géants le dernier des très
jeu donc tu es la naissance du guy
savez pour changer beaucoup d'ailleurs
john wayne cinq clôtures de l'autre côté
guerre venu avec nous société mamère
je suis quand même très très ému mais
d'ulrich à béliveau calaf là qu'est ce
maurice richard en 2000 il y avait eu
patinoire a été aussi souvent relatés on
theron
monde est là chaque duel les gens sont
possible mais ça dépend de la demande 1
entouré de lui
commencé comme vous savez sa carrière à
aujourd'hui on apris encore plus époque
préparer mentalement bien sûr qui avait
appelaient
des héros populaires au niveau des
aller au saguenay
récents en même temps alors voilà c'est
je voudrais qu ce qu'elles m'ont 10
claude quenneville et qu'une quinzaine
exceptionnel et je pense que s'il ya une
soleil qui s'était lui au bout du fil
steve shot il veut s'adapter a dit la
vous êtes tellement on est content que
maison mes parents mes parent ait émigra
personnes tout le monde voulait plus la
il faut y aller livrer des hélicos
vraiment très terre à terre près des
d'un jour d'eau le matin mais c'était
politiciens les artistes se coller à guy
quant aux garanties
dire que c'est se dit un peu
on devait rencontrer dans la version us
cancer du poumon puis après il a dit oui
terre à terre qui était près des gens
quelques questions du 2 3 questions en
beaucoup de souvenirs
guide n'est pas juste un
niveau culturel comme la fleur a eu si
président des relations publiques du
et comme le tricolore arrache une coupe
je lisais un article je pense d yvan
plus tôt dans l'émission vous a dit
déposé une paire de gants il ya aussi
équipe de l'histoire qui à cet honneur
plus familial il veut pas familiale à
notre réalisateur qui réalise les
mais n'empêche quand ça arrive qu'un
qui est réalisateur et une phrase qui me
regrette laila du ca se départir de lui
grosse mesdames et dans ma chevelure
ans et demi on a voyagé ensemble à
a parlé on va y aller chapelle ardente à
casse qui étaient
fonctionné et dont on lui demande
déjà plus de cent mille personnes quitte
hommages nationaux des hommages de ce
vécues avec aigle affaires j'oserais qui
c'est comme ça ça il y avait claude
juste avec les rapports si j'ai toujours
pourquoi le pourquoi son niveau de jeu
c'est un voyage dans le temps avec guy
louis martineau vous voir parler à des
qui disent on va sortir pauvres vivant
audition maps et s'était pas mis à la
étaient vraiment le fun de côtoyer même
est ce qui fait d'un train de prendre
mais là ça des maisons vides oui vous ce
voir dans la sur la patinoire ou partie
rare dans le salon du bon dieu il passe
de traitements ça avec moi je voulais
verre à contrer dans le salon dans
lui offrir un contrat sur le champ
même moment qui a réagi et c'est là
mais c'est important ce que je dis pas
pense que dans ton documentaire jean
téléphone on va rétablir la
grands qui nous ont quittés le dernier
j'aurais tout donné
pas contents le suisse qui se profile
démon blond compte 30 but en 33 matchs
l'assemblée nationale beaucoup de fans
pour revoir
c'est pas facile
patrick roy aussi il parlait la
pas de préparation physique comme
je passe avec les meilleures séries pour
mais c'est un ensemble jean françois
d'une certaine façon je me demande où
les taux étaient pour le public qui m
québec ce en octobre dernier et je
figures qui trans posé qui transperce
à côté heat est venu faire
s'est il appartenait au peuple errant
qu'avant d'être un grand joueur à qui il
que ça aurait fait ça me fait chaud au
lafleur après repêché par le canadien de
flotte donc il pose la question à la
vous soyez là dedans que vous disiez
français peut-être la même chose en
dit y'a pas faire juste un pack avec ses
moyen oui je peux parler de lui je
il le disait j attends toi que guy
deux profs
club de hockey canadienne des affaires
inspiration piano plusieurs missions
ces événement spécial c'est comme quand
gens alors à sa demande c'est de la
choc
puis eux même parler des dix la soeur de
jusqu'à à houston jusqu à dallas au
bongo oui fumée bleue mais quand on s'en
et où le canadien était extrême à 2001
lafleur il on le voit pierre trudeau
il faut en parler parce que je dois dire
stanley inattendue au printemps 1973 le
ce qu'on veut voir l'extrait dans votre
des gerbes de fleurs et on a prévu le
là au temple de la renommée depuis
faussement décoiffée bel aplomb c'est
rencontrés un petit peu plus tôt
de rock et puis vous savez aussi que
je me souviens de guy lafleur beaucoup
c'était lui qui était il était comme ça
excellent choix doc est un des maires de
qui venaient souvent salué bon sa
aujourd'hui les joueurs à l'époque
françois poirier on vous entend dit
l'ouest de montréal avant on avait eu un
puis je faisais un la file de souffre
près nulles
avec toi moi je voulais que la marche
en a plusieurs d'ailleurs le maire de
revient à l'esprit c'est celle de petter
une société puis oui je reconnus mais je
missions il se souvient qu'il a traversé
deuxième c'était la meilleure et il y
nom des funérailles officielles sa vie
précédente et de réponse parce qu'on
la fleur se mêlaient dans une réponse
à aller défiler rendre un dernier
l'occasion
une heure avec lui bertrand les bons
est déclinée aussi rapidement par la
vingt le canadien de montréal mesdames
du garde puis mcgilberry en rajoute on
lafleur étant à nouveau le monde yoaké
qu'on peut regarder ce qu'avait à dire
d'avoir du courage chez les valeurs que
dans notre poche pas de panier jeu pas
anglais un peu moins toujours sur le
vous avez eu le meilleur des deux vous
je vois fut même j'étais jeune je sais
cournoyer qui disait qu elle flingue il
poirier merci beaucoup pour cette
documentaire il s'en veut lui louis ils
bah je cherche mais tout le monde le
100 et puis dimanche j'ai su qu'il était
lafleur on le sait monter de manière à
une promotion je vous le rappelle
qui a fait à ce point rêver tout un
maintenant des années je vous montre
gens là c'est partout le les réactions
durant la joute politique on fait
flamme qu'est-ce que je peux faire donc
sauf pour les journées match les zones
d'inspiration qui doit nous suscité nous
coeur
nous formuler
dans le vestiaire puis aussi robert
aujourd'hui
comme nos otages
situation des remparts je trouve
montréal ça commence pas si fort un bon
parlais des trois grands
si à l'extérieur il faisait ses
et deux types de finir un officiel et
ses goûts c'était dit martin st-louis un
parlais de vue je peux me souvenir de
aux gens d'arrêter de fumer parce que
réjean tremblay il dit vous avez dit le
larochelle à québec aussi tu sais je je
compte bloqué alors jésus dit geler le
aide publique les doigts
monsieur vous ça m'a frappé dans votre
disait c'est la fleur qui dirigeait la
a été comme nous tous
texas si c'était c'est comme si il était
c'est moi
pour lui parce que dans le temps c'est
suite mais il est arrivé des choses dans
participation à cette émission un
était mal coach et il était comment guy
ait un excellent à gaudi qui perd un
coup on a même mis des projecteurs
lafleur maurice richard jean béliveau
cette nouvelle
stachnick a pu jouer avec lui pistache
du
veux reconnaître que sans vous ce serait
lui dire de partir parce que monsieur
plus jeune vous rêviez de devenir la
famille qui est encore présente dans la
souvent référence soit ok lors des
dîner dans le pendant l'été avec
hommage et on peut présumer que ça va
gary bettman que j'ai traduit bien sûr
avait avec ma les cinq dernières années
de passer dans la mesure où cela
lafleur barbelés qui est en train de
façon qu'ils ont installé bon la statue
plus de l'homme qui était de 8 et on se
ce qu'ils faisaient samedi montpellier
qu'on peut dire ça de personne quand
chez nous pour le reste chez moi oui oui
qui
thurso vous allez entendre dans les
soir ben moi deux facettes un message et
sujet du jour le premier disque du
éveiller qu'il nous invite à janvier
guy lafleur et guy effet d'une façon
concernant un référendum où le
comment s'est présenté pour une partie
arrivent de partout oui on s'est
statistiques
pour être meilleur avec toi et la flore
et messieurs va parler dans 15 minutes
les funérailles d'état funérailles
sa peau est évident pour lui un sa peau
bourassa avant avec les remparts qui
le peuple aime boire en quelqu'un et
moi ça m'a ça m'a coûté ultime à ma
ce que vous le vivez au même moment au
important de rappeler que les remparts
fout de tout ce que c'était des joueurs
match lui passer trois heures sans
sa vie personnelle
voyez pas ce que je vous entends je vois
tout l'état met l'humain hors glace j'ai
richard béliveau et lui il raconte que
va tâcher la tête alors la flotte pointe
le fameux cassen lesnevien ses charges à
savait d'où il venait puis il était
donnerait plus ménagé j'avais mon échec
rentré nice n'est pas lié à cette
lui le savez pas changé il a été plus
répétition alors c'est certain que ça a
lafleur n'était pas content de son
documentaire quand les journées les
c'est
et 17 1 go avec moi du moins il était
peuple qui le dernier qui a incarné le
disent pas la hauteur près comme un
si
conférences de presse c'est comme si la
prochains deux secondes il est presque
la rue il est avec son père ils sont ils
de a tramp sûrement
autour de la statue parce qu'on sait que
région mais aussi ses proches d'ailleurs
dans la lnh malheureusement pour lui son
compagnon de la maman elle-même j'ai vu
spécial je le rappelle votre
ne sais pas lequel d'un du monde je sais
pas trop et sur la fleur est ce que vous
se passe chez guy lafleur
lafleur ige veille détour ce que les
nationales parce que si on parlerait de
savait puis surtout nous la dernière
peuple de gauche regarde mal je t'aime
centraliser et choisir une chose ils
coéquipier
ça la peau ce fort quand même 30 but
monsieur ronald traoré puis réjean houle
on sera là en direct pour avoir le point
entrevues était un petit peu direct
je suis honorée à sherbrooke il ya 500
bien qu'en termes de taux puis qu'est ce
ça va dans le dépassement de soi
corps de seconde qui a perdu il l'a
s'il ya une chapelle ardente vous allez
dit il avait rencontré pour la première
sur le spic nom et
ici il a signé bien entendu de
remontée de diverses leur une le nouveau
chamboulé son horaire évidemment on a dû
rien ce serait pas de sens que de jouer
ces sédiments qu'on est on s'est dit bon
de hockey de haut niveau tu sais comme
fleur vous avez joué avec lui
maurice richard il ya eu une émeute à
reflète
immense et semblait filer qu'ils étaient
je suis pas pareil parce que il n'ya pas
joute politique se faisait souvent avec
canadien suite à servette rythme ce qui
conversation
sociales qu est-ce qu est-ce qui fait
souvient de ses exploits
cdta la kia qui vient qui parle une fois
fédéralisme ça faisait la une partout et
aventuré dans des arénas de sac dès ce
cercle vicieux qui s'installe pays sur
prodigue notre retour au pays dominés là
pour vous alors un extrait il dit il
désir à suivre son sillon son passage
surnoms vous avez fait quoi les cet été
lui dit ben je peux pas te le dire de
tellement gentil ça va être l'un des
même moment où ça se passe alors c'est
mieux s'organiser mais mais l'appel que
être beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde
plus mais je vous ai atteint guy
on parlait des parrains de comparer en
c'est une question pour garder parce que
est évident pour lui lui qui attire
traitement comme ambassadeur bon tout ça
quand quelqu'un comme ça les à peu près
déjà trembler merci beaucoup de nous
parce qu'on savait que ça s'en venait
ont réussi là où on le voit on le voit
à boston et ce soir-là du but 2 passes
là il a signé son bâton et encore le
c'est lui qui s'est intéressé à tout le
documentaire est à voir puis on va faire
nallet au phare à limoges mais j'allais
ville oui mais je suis tout seul et le
courage qui incarne et bien sûr la
voisins avec la mère de guy lafleur il
un hymne à un aimant exactement pour
finir à une nationale lorsque les
que la flanelle assez mal à voir où les
n'est de guy lafleur on s'en attendait
de ce vestiaire vous avez le chandail de
moins deux bandes d'asnières et est
leurs qui comme trame de fond aucune
il ne faisait pas que parler de hockey
de morgen puis tout le monde t'aime et
continuer
c'est pas le même genre de personnage à
prudent on surveillait la situation il
a été vite au bureau du premier ministre
autres pensaient tout bas bas qui
mais quand on a la chance on a eu la
j étais
fois à la coupe canada 76 alors qu'ils
les gens vont venir se recueillir
son jeu flamboyant bien sûr ribéry côté
sais pas c'est certainement celle que
déjà dit ce soir là
pour mettre en forme des hommes je joue
accepteriez de parler j'ai 21 ans 22 ans
matin où il ya encore quelques ligue de
jambes il dit tu vas voir guy la vie ça
impressionnés
motion
tout ben évidemment ça devient plus
aurait eu à donner un emploi puis
perdue dans l'alcool et perdu d'arrivée
des dieux ces termes au québec alors eu
allez manas béliveau on imagine rendent
personne simple qu'il était aussi en
de presse convoqué maire de québec pour
monde soasta guy laflamme puis
l'idée du documentaire
marché canadien est à la flamme
exactement comme lui parfois possible de
mais on est devant
je pense à chaque page après un but de
a été rétabli après au téléphone
fouette et qu'est ce que c'est que ça
funérailles d'état s'est dit réservé en
qu'on ait dit oui ça fait mal mais mes
toute façon moi même je ne sais pas ce
après la quatrième conquête de
j'ai pas vraiment vu des joints
nombreuses autographes pour des jeunes
guy lafleur ça coïncide avec le moment
que vous voyez vous avez vu la carrière
aussi vite dans ce registre complète
qui voudront aller rendre un dernier
n'était pas nécessaire de voir le nom et
jusqu'à tard ce soir on a même nettoyer
j'ai été élevé mois
peu de mots ses médecins que je suis
importance là pas seulement pour les
guy lafleur entouré de celui de la
on prend soin d'eux énormément les
bougent travaille fort mais il faut
personnes dans la salle et naturellement
parler des parents de guy lafleur
à le jeu vous un peu
oui ça vaut la peine je les ai vus
martin oui ils ont été créés pour ainsi
me reposer pendant le dernier quart
lorsqu'il se déplaçait le maire disait
l'intérieur donc c'est ça avec vous il
ce matin pour essayer de
en sorte que cela soit su tout au long
ambassadeur de première map poupe pour
bâton particulière notre ami rédacteur
tout de suite à cinq anglais et le train
lafleur avait à cause d'eux en anglais
par génération
rendu toujours un plaisir de vous parler
aujourd'hui encore
performance sportive mais au-delà de
sons à la nation canadienne française
un peu au tennis puis j'ai marché mais
1,55 puis ça a mené à la révolution
on par un grand homme je suis vraiment
deux vieux chums qui fait ça sont au
fallait prendre ça tout de même au
hockey amateur qui sont en activité et
parce qu'il faut se rappeler à cette
c'est ce qu'ont qu'on veut de nos joies
l'instant dire que je pense que les
général au président de l'assemblée
légendaire qui était vendu que ça y est
puis du lot les journalistes qui
le canadien gagne 4 à 2 et gagne la
même quand dans des carrières
fille et tu voyais qu'ils étaient
derrière tous
journée de sa faillite c'était la
robinson 19 serge savard 18 et le fameux
grand que nature merci martin on se
jouent pour la tchécoslovaquie veille
mesdames et messieurs c'est vous la
c'est qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
allemand dans l'histoire d'un peuple les
kuyt du staff
on va tout le monde est avec toi le
que je vais faire quand je rentre en
généreux surtout et moi j'ai passé de
puis deux autres en nette hausse était
chance de le côtoyer l'homme qui était
où il avait retiré son casque oui il
ma mère est décédée
ma peau mais si je regarde camel ou
parle de la fierté de la mer sa fierté
le numéro de guy lafleur sur son
1979 et des joueurs importants qui sont
toute la classe puisse-t-elle vedette
hommage à monsieur lafleur à sa famille
regrouper il va rebondir dans l'hymne
d'heure pour être prêt pour le pas sur
puis a terminé il yves dû me donner
avec les as de québec après lire la page
je le sens bien donc c'est un seul autre
qui jouaient au hockey et il venait
fans de rock et comme sport mais pour
parler aux médias la demande était très
un dernier hommage à ben oui je dois
concours de circonstances on a rencontré
peine ce soir 20h donc r d les livres
quelqu'un qui a joué avec lui jusqu'à 60
à procéder bangor des des hommes du
fin
époque là ce n'est pas la même vie à
condoléances monsieur plouf alors voilà
extraordinaire et des moments qui vont
dire pour guy lafleur les remparts là
de monsieur lafleur ou avec quelles
sérieux mais on est des succès un réseau
de la journée mesdames et messieurs
condoléances pour doivent peut-être
nationale ou à l'ancien premier ministre
chargés dans le documentaire qu'on ne
comme mesure elle note b you mais ça
passe vite
au 18 heures qui a presque les larmes
des photos de vue un peu partout fetter
cela le courage le courage de dire les
vieilles suivi la belle chambre d'hôtel
d'un daltin moderne je pense qu'on a
guy prend le micro pour
division on était tous les fans de guy
zone adverse donc de cette manière dont
toujours le plus frappé santé à vous je
une carrière une carrière partiellement
vous comme pas drôle jusqu'à la dernière
on va on va on va rappeler ses intérêts
bon qui est souvent ils avaient des
aujourd'hui des geeks qui se tiennent en
fumeur sur le banc pour faire un dut qui
était épaté par ce qu'elle avait entendu
est en partie le très brève à partir
un bel homme ou un grand amateur d'art
était
hills et flers à cause de cette allure
ou
tchad puis
couvrent le canadien s'entendent pour
la statue et c'est vraiment touchant de
tranquille mais lafleur a explosé puisse
puis avec sa corvette avec son
en partant en moto pour s'arranger pour
mal et des moments de noirceur on est
était pas bien puis dans votre
chandail lorsque deux fois avait la
patrice beaucoup de retraités donc des
québec comme un vrai territoire avec la
reparle tout à l'heure et liz allaire
c'est ce que patrick roy seule fois j'ai
l'organisation non seulement c'était le
lui même à lui lorsqu'il recevait un
l'imaginaire collectif dans son ensemble
puis c'est la journée avant le premier
souvent faire son tour ici aussi parce
partis comme jacques lemaire comme ken
merci de votre attention ça va bien sûr
guy lafleur puis quand il venait à être
s'adressait deux parties du québec sinon
d'études et emploie 2 2 le présent telle
deux choses qui rassemble plus une
manier revient d'un été qui dit
national ça fait qu'un guerre venu avec
hier j'étais
série en quatre parties guy lafleur a
très bons moments avec lui faisait
numéro 10 de guy lafleur à ses gants en
fait marc durand et moi
parisot
discussions familiales avec lui alors on
univers mais il se préparer mentalement
il ya quand même un protocole qui est
que j' y est c'est son épouse qui s'est
trop souvent trop souvent où la plupart
25 ha pour le blé foram à l'époque lui
il n'y avait pas besoin d'être comme ça
similitudes qui qu'est-ce que vous quel
donner chaque stade option qu'il a été
c'était les as de québec auparavant à
forte et je suis convaincu que le projet
aux yeux quand il nous raconte qu'il a
on peut pas me contrer alors steve shot
je me sens tellement bien accueilli par
documentaire qu'on verra à erdil je
donc avant des funérailles nationales ça
minute jusqu'à son terme il souffle
derrière pour des médias ça touche et
on est sûrs on a eu avec les canadiens
met dessus deux paquets avait mais deux
choses le courage de faire rêver parce
18 je crois pierre bouchard monsieur
des îles peu joyeux mais il va par
d'entrevue village était figée
de gamme day qui avait qui avait fait
vous êtes au centre bell vous êtes avec
peuple étaient gentils les panels temps
usage du canadien ces
être là musicale pour aller manger au
dryden et le profil a commencé à changer
rendre à
d'abord comme on attendra qui comme
tout le québec parce que on a
j'ai déjà mais il ya des six musulmans
et plusieurs personnes avec qui on peut
c'est ce sont des témoignages comme ça
gens qui ont eu l'occasion de voir
encore aujourd'hui je gagne 3 mais dès
reste que dans le cas de la fleur
nation c'est la culture et le sport plus
les rangers de new york du camaq au tout
capable s'en sortir on est capable de
les cheveux blancs quand il patinait
qui heureusement ne pas assez comme du
meilleur joueur de l'histoire des
du régime a dit moi je travaille à
personne qui aurait voulu vivre une
qui ont réagi dans les équipes vont
meilleurs joueurs on l'a beaucoup sont
que sa famille est présente au maire est
on l'a terminé la semaine dernière et la
rondelle aussi élégant que
lambada par les hérésies stephen lang le
match des séries quand les canadiens qui
eu une ovation pour un an
se poursuivre cette programmation il ya
lafleur on était tous voulaient tous se
alors qu'ils ont été
appel de celui qu'il appelle son idole
amener là la prise du pouvoir par le
l'organisation et à cette époque là tous
voir des gens de partout on entendu tout
suivie mais il faut la volonté des
à ce moment alors pour savoir que ce qui
provoqué leur
vu la belle chambre d'hôtel c'est très
mais aussi joie qui sont persévérants
sait ça monsieur monsieur lafleur était
parallèle vous faites avec votre mari
quelqu'un lui pose un journaliste que
évoluer guy lafleur du début jusqu'à la
parler son jeune peut-être trop jeune
du temps mauvais des photos de jésus oui
sans vous rappeler guy carbonneau
là il y avait comme une confrérie puis
je me souviens qu'elle ait pas que
bouchard bonjour oui bonjour peu plus
lui répond alors qu'est ce que je fais
comme comme comme dit lafleur dans mon
hélicoptère avec il y avait une vie
du teil et s infiltre
mexique l'avion à deux jours encore
vous sais byron au revoir ronald corey
avec les cheveux au vent et ensuite et
arrêté ici une à s'asseoir dans mon
chose que ce qu'ils entraînent des
totalement je rencontrais mon idole
eau ici et on a déjà qui sont venus il
penser à des hommes comme lui d'autres
mais je comprends tout à fait
l'impression de perdre quelqu'un qui
joueur c'est un cachet unique parce que
remparts mais tout en plus utile une
ailleurs j'ai choisi de se retirer cc
on retient le plus c'était des héros
sera précisé un peu plus tard
mcgill à montréal et
mikes guittet là ya pas une personne qui
encore le fameux bâton que guy lafleur
je viens d orthographe mais peu importe
réagir en a je crois la diact de la guy
comme dirait jean perron qui jouait avec
c'était à cause essaie t en fais quand
avec les angels puis guy lafleur et jean
a sorti différentes photos de lui l'ont
que comme slogan qui ont un qui ont
encore présente ici alors jusqu'au
par l'air puis des
remarquablement talentueux lafleur était
des gens qui commencent à arriver pour
qu'on récolte depuis le début de la
début la première à sa première année ça
par guy lafleur et toute l'organisation
qu'il l'a fait rêver des gens avec son
fin de sa carrière est unanimement
nom assez directe de la sa franchise
dit et je te demande et moi j'aime pas
représentation qu'ils n'aillent et
ces menaces ne pas simplement les fumis
puis comment vous le décrivez vous comme
proches donc l'heure de ce qu'on
battre pour qu'ils allaient avoir le
liés depuis ce matin dans les années 70
le point de presse monsieur legault à 14
pour commenter tout ça d'ailleurs vous
pour jouer avec toi m'at il dit ça c'est
ce qu'ils ont été
plus tôt fumer le chichon haschisch
ça c'est moi mais je ne devrais pas tous
pour avoir connu guy lafleur dans ses
pts qui sait les débuts de carrière de
meetic ou six accidents fameux accident
jean françois qui disait lui reconnu le
soudeur travailler dans une vie rend
vous avez fait ce territoire je joue un
dans le sport une des personnes les plus
personnes hommes et femmes qui même
bâtons et des militaires méticuleux et
comme journaliste et à la fin petite
cigarettes entier période mrsa permet de
était proche de nous quelqu'un des notes
bureau pour prendre un café bonjour ça
d'apple était pour tenir un grand joueur
première première réaction pierre
jeu question entend adresser ce qu'ils
il a atteint la trentaine
national de maurice richard niveau et
effrayant prends soin de moi comme ça
les meilleurs espoirs québécois allait
seul à la fatalité de cette situation et
comprend c'est qu'une discussion avec
puits comme je dis c'est pas le visage
il y avait des choses évident qu'il
à l'heure une famille de la
numéro 10 dans l'équipe que ce soit dans
journée j'ai même parlé à un guide ici
je rate un déjeuner avec jean béliveau
j'arrête souvent jose avec sa maman puis
calgary 2-1 puis je m'adresser canadien
lui a autographié avec gentillesse
parti québécois l'affirmation nationale
termine sa carrière avec lui puisqu'il
personne qui ait quitté disponible c'est
pas de casque et donc c'était ça avait
je comprends tout à fait merci et réjean
pratiquement tous ces gens là nous ont
bon tennis et tout ça ça va rien à voir
quelqu'un que marquer l'histoire et au
mode de vie avec sa proximité
encore cette magie lieu d'aller chercher
étaient petits ou grands lacs à la pause
jjd frac royal tours et d'argent ouais
dernier moment bien entendu pas
famille lafleur était au courant de ce
aujourd'hui il est de thurso guy lafleur
évidemment j'ai eu la grande chance de
aussi c'était encore quatre balles des
et dans les mac ce succès
ça il raconte sur le kick salle lachal l
ton problème c'est comme ceux qui
la cause des sorts il fait ce que
une silhouette est comparable celle fois
rendre un dernier hommage à monsieur
lafleur un joueur est un compétiteur
rôles sont présentés au service de ma
m'a pas surpris du tout parce que c'est
ensemble et on parle de proda sport on
début mais tant qu'à s'en fait remarquer
madame niveau oui jean francheteau
dans une usine à thurso il n'était pas
ex-président du canadien avec nous de ce
parquet milanais la tête presque tout
meilleures années avec le canadien mais
nouvelle-écosse venir se recueillir et
heures pour les détails des funérailles
les proches de guy lafleur pour savoir
c'est bien je pense qu'on donne des dsl
fallait faire mais à l'extérieur ou si
puis tout arrêt avec l'esp est jetée
ya quelques minutes à peine déposé une
joueur puis comme cela fleure bon l
quand ça va bien on vit des périodes
béliveau
toujours comparer tout statut s'est
guy lafleur au pot nécessairement été le
bouchard un grand joueur évidemment un
beaucoup de réactions évidemment depuis
dit que ça avait été un exemple
jouer dans la ligue junior ontarienne le
gens bien jean perron a gagné la coupe
prénom
us canadien juste parce que le joueur de
aimés une personne qui a fait le plus
pensent qu'ils avaient pas devenu
même pas pour l'appeler l'ange blond
s'est mis à fréquenter un peu plus les
tape sur l'épaule
connotations c'est
des jeunes effectivement très à l'aube
booster à la fumée 2 3 portes puis jetée
plus tard merci patrice est on va on va
meilleur des deux mondes enfin
en est où ça aurait pu 13 88 grosse
doit constater de la part des québécois
set c'était des expériences
la rue l'été ou sur une patinoire
répondaient qu'ils la france
emblématique il est une légende de notre
une personne qui était accessible c'est
difficiles et ont réussi à émerger et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire lorsqu'on
lorsqu'il était très malade mais il
déterminant dans leur vie guy lafleur
moi je disais je vais aller plutôt pas
trois grains moi je me rappelle quand
parla de femmes existent ce quelqu'un
qui se souviennent quand même de lui
arrêtait du l'impliquer dans l'art qui
et à la flore
tellement fait à pas nous racontent
chez lui puis
c'est un jeu pauvre et présente un pou
delà de la clé 4 extraordinaire parce
ici lorsqu'il jouait justement dans
corps et bonjour bonjour je veux c'est
quand on a vu du bon match puis c'est
qui la flamme et ces gars là ont un
les gens il y avait eu dans votre cas
qui est humain terlet été fait et on
chaque fois qu'il dévalait la glace du
gerbe de fleurs des québécois qui sont
au centre bell qui m'a dit j'ai déjà
un vrai c c'est un geek du talent
chapelle ardente je présume car un lieu
idées mode c'est ok
meurent comme un vrai tueur marc pour
non mais regarde aujourd'hui avant
aussi facile qu'on que la exemple en ce
jean-françois vous restez là on va
dans la société québécoise et ailleurs
appui qui aimait mieux être libre
comme artistes amateurs s'étaient
vraiment intéressés par l'europe qui il
j'accompagne patrice dans cette émission
il n'y avait pas assez des messages
de ma carrière que cinq coupes stanley
parfois ça le mise à l'eau chaude à
décide que des funérailles officielles
vibrer les québécois c'est guy laflamme
qu'il avait auprès des gens on en parle
les jeunes de toucher les gens je
stanley puis à
si nos gènes peut dévier il ya d alice
comparé depuis ses records ont été
une personne qui était très généreuse de
ils allaient pratiquer faisaient déjà il
joueur c'est un message important ce
bars à avoir une vie mondaine plus
c'est que guy lafleur était le maradona
claudine richard vous êtes sur place
pour les packs qu'il a eu sur l'ensemble
j'ai amené à la ligue nationale je suis
extérieure qu'un des voisins avec la
église c'était tellement rigolé tu as
vous aviez gagné la coupe de la coupe
venait presque à chaque mois en
ce matin sur les réseaux sociaux
hockey guy c'est
adolescent il est inspiré par guy
il me disait devoir sa
extraordinaires on va se laisser sur
béliveau il dit piggy en revenant avec
qui aime sa famille qui mêle à la
que dans certains cas ça les avait
en visite par hasard à toronto et qui
émerger de façon extraordinaire mais ça
dans les émotions et la part de martin
si je le garde pour wii et là
ce qui est du cap content que tu dises à
oui on voit les gens là qui se
feu dans les toilettes
toutes sortes d'histoires de la carrière
forum de montréal ces longues mèches
puis finalement pour le show ça a été
je fais longtemps ne serait pas du tout
du panache puis c'est m'en donnez là là
spéciale
entendre monsieur lafleur par les deux
cac 40 a signé des autographes pu parler
en reste là le besoin vous reste avec
sport il nous manquera nous pensées sont
que j'ai envie de souligner deux
mémoire de monsieur lafleur ce que tu
témoigner encore des souvenirs de guy
me met sur terre à cette nomination
point en commun ces gars-là stade il y
avait rendez vous avec la famille de la
monter il est connu partout et surtout
directs est clair mais c'est un bloc est
occupé on le disait avec les jeunes
a comment ils ce sont les voisins ses
des trams mais
la société québécoise par delà le sport
passé quelques heures avec monsieur
projetés jeune j'écoutais le terrain que
stanley à quatre participants +14
son hôte et puis
une belle cérémonie par mon dieu oui
ce côté là exceptionnel vous bon vous
quelques reprises c'est un jean béliveau
je vous ramène en 1971 le 9 juin le
marie-eve bégin un petit tour d'horizon
battus par les mac bosser la semaine
il ya une collaboration de l'état
hélicoptère on lui avait même a réservé
reprendre tout ça c
mon père aussi spécialement mais c'est
junior ontarienne les meilleurs espoirs
entre autres c'est un électron libre
parlait de ces situations vinet larme à
faire ça donc guy lafleur j'allais je ne
cadillac rentrer chez lui tard le soir
il y avait à l'écart la date dans femme
moment
poussés également s'intéresser au hockey
je voudrais absolument
communauté de thurso c'est quelqu'un qui
comme ça et c'est comme ça mon premier
regarde juste qu'est ce que
sa peinture me choque le plus gros de
fait tes aimable avec tout le monde et
lafleur il voulait devenir lafleur et il
naturel comme ça se vende bien du temps
réaction qui les poches de thurso il y
faisait déjà puis ça s'est poursuivi
fla pour le présenter à monsieur lafleur
cette très belle phrase serge savard
des québécois c'est comme ce qu'il il
moi j'ai un avis étaient 6,4 à bainghen
à montréal évidemment un lieu à québec
tout l'orgueil pour une fois sans jésus
peut-être remettre en lumière certaines
maké cinq dernières années et autant
lafleur et il nous parlait tout
de guipy c'est tellement plaisant
suppose la résilience suppose d'avoir
connu et à son à berthier aux makes it
blondes flottant dans son sillage
une soirée magique pour pour tous les
occasions de toute façon n'était pas
aussi mais surtout si nous la paiera
trembler tout allait bien
voisins de surchauffe
lafleur j'aimerais qu'on écoute quelques
avec toi on part des hommes avec des
prends un vide et c'est qu'on a tous en
prouve sa part cette
st-louis une nouvelle comme ça quand il
était très ému de pouvoir être ici le
gentillesse de monter pendant l'hiver et
depuis ce matin avec des gens qui l'ont
d'ailleurs avec parts son fils martin
avec sa famille l'organisation des
on ne peut pas vraiment comprendre ce
j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour son acom
québécois qui s'entend avec la famille
parmi les commentaires qui reviennent
l'oeil puis des retards restent ali ils
mais l'électron les bouées servi
réjean tremblay moi j'y suis allé
souvenir de guy lafleur dans l'uniforme
j'adore je t'ai dit de suite ça dure
vous dit vous avez été choyé de jouer
lui même j'ai parlé un peu plus tôt à
a pu jouer finalement avec lui dans les
tête l'image du démon blond qui fait ce
des modèles et je pense que guy lafleur
carrie presse exemple joseph
des beaux souvenirs
mon père je me suis jetée très jeune
comme marcel diane c'était courant que
la rade est le mode meilleur alentours
meilleur compteur de but il y avait une
ouais effectivement il faut spécifier
l'ont fait mais peut-être trop peu c'est
dire que le trio a joué le chant des
un terrain où il pouvait atterrir parce
l'avez connu vous avez débuté avec un
d'écouter cette dame parler d'eux avec
l'eau peut-être quelques voix près
moi tout le temps les mecs tic les
seuls devant l'inévitable
simplement de ses hélicoptères de sa
avec les remparts une de ses grandes
lorsqu'il se préparait à tirer une autre
fier je pense que je compatis comme
à l'écouter le premier mené du canada
passants rencontrés ce matin qui met
aimait parler de la ville de thurso l'a
de ben et puis il fumait de tours
lafleur qui est juste derrière moi
difficile de passer à côté un compte
dit situation mais c'était
connu avec des gens qui ne l'ont pas
question que le canadien change dit
faisait l'image de cet homme dans we
quand j'ai pas lui un mois il était
le petit 8e ou le quart de seconde qui
forcent à 20 avant eux et guy lafleur
plus que toute autre personnalité que
par exemple n'aurait jamais osé dire sur
dernière qui nous a quittés
gens le zèle jusqu'à personne du moment
bien apprécié et ce n'est pas terminé
écoute tu devrais peut-être pas assez à
régulièrement outre ses exploits sur la
un soir il y avait compté trois obus
entraînait
puis en fait dans la nuit puis la mort
canadiens de montréal ou toronto mais
non maggie le taureau et mais on ne te
en est certainement un et je ferai
pour prendre en charge une partie du
vendredi le jour où mike bossy est
revenait souvent
dirigeait pas longtemps parce qu'elle
dominique anglade chef de l'opposition
souvent à son max paix gelé vue ouïe
j'avais 10 ans qu'il te voir la fleur
nuit j'ai 19 ans a pour sa possible que
dépensé de loin de la patinoire il y
que ça représente autres avant de gagner
malheureusement sur le nombre de saisons
viandes à deux jours encore
promotion jean marc fournier est bien là
repos ton histoire d'ailleurs du bac qui
le 3 ou
canadien a gagné la coupe stanley votre
puis moi perso mais j'ai eu la chance
beaucoup ils disent ce qu'ils pensent et
des nordiques de québec hier sa
vieillir
jour où on annoncé malheureusement le
d'ailleurs on peut voir des gerbes de
canettes les 3es jeux tu étais trois
de lui parce que il ya du talent un
fiertés avec téhéran pas parce qu'elle
beaucoup connu mais qui ont été touchés
que bon dans le passé il essayé
la résilience de l'homme c'est la
que la nouvelle a d'abord été partagé
grand champion
années 80 oui puis enfin comment qu'il a
avec la bénédiction du de sont pas et
rondelle devant un gardien impuissant ou
français compte 15 ans et les puits
la fierté qu'elle avait peur pour son
tous un petit mot à dire sur guy lafleur
officielle et paul st pierre plamondon
martens une bonne image effectivement
les jeunes québécois elle décide d'aller
jamais oublié ses racines même si la
l'aréna taton qui joue pour nous le voir
ont souvenir puis rencontre de deux
peuvent que je te fais toi leur par la
mais lui 8 redire ça plupart tard ibis
prit sa retraite pour la suite et et un
d'après moi je veux devenir président
j'ai connu moi cette avance patrice qui
famille c'était vraiment un homme comme
qu'il veut sur la patinoire avec sa
lafleur lui n'était pas question de
glace en dehors de la glace on retient
qui verrait agit actuellement
monique richard c'est la même chose non
tenu de l'importance de québec pour
cette offre - gap arsenal si vous êtes
justement d'être repêché par le canadien
processus et déterminé qu est-ce qui va
avec des vedettes comme ça deux sets de
de suite de 5 ans but il en a plus que
goût de parler bientôt j'imagine la
diminué que les mesures n'a jamais ça le
mari jean béliveau annonce sa retraite
pour leafs les canadiens de montréal
manquait des fois c'était peut-être le
à
ce qui est agréable quand convient dans
manque une saison où je me souviens qu'à
fleurs des photos où les gens apportent
points il y avait plusieurs jeunes
abstraction de l'ensemble de ses
avait une connexion avec la population
sur le côté gauche touch abus c'est une
personnes identique au niveau personnel
était juste à côté un le poteau juste
capacité de l'homme de passer à travers
aussi qu'ils étaient justement peut-être
où il ya sauté sur la patinoire pendant
2020 en pleine pandémie cg je travaille
on se dit toujours moi je m'informais
d'atterrir sur un terrain de soccer et
décédé et le rendez-vous a été annulé la
combo très peu de joie dans qui peuvent
c'est dur arrêté pu prendre sa retraite
tête tu es un gros moule que s'apprête à
jouer en ontario pour améliorer leurs
n'est pas concret la ligue de hockey
le dit monsieur pleure un homme du
garçon qui arrivait souvent que il
vont être remplacés de votre crédit
c'est
je pense que vieillir aujourd'hui c'est
coéquipiers extraordinaire
l'envoyer au sein d'une autre équipe
de montréal puis d'être son coéquipier
ça mais
crinière de cheveux dans le vent voire
par la soeur de guy lafleur sur son
suite on voit le défilé par vous parler
par lui avec des rencontres à
on retient de l'homme un individu qui
consomme à la cigarette concernant le
vont réagir dans quelques minutes on
venir par la suite on devrait avoir ces
monsieur lafleur merci de votre
mots signés pour mes enfants les chaque
double et de l'excellence parce que ça
de prix pour
avait eu un joint qui s'étaient échappés
partie très jeune au torse jamais oublié
jouer parce que c'était nomena village
décès du démon blond guy lafleur est pas
global pas le souhaite on a eu dix
ses qualités athlétiques bien sûr mais
à préparer un coéquipier pour un but
verre de trop la veille mais mais c'est
et surtout ils se sont sentis très
junior majeur du québec et on joue
mais dans ces 10
vrai mais c'est un bon garçon et à faire
restera je m'assure qu'elle vit la vie
parce que c'était un monument
mais ça a été un de ceux qui a supporté
souris puis d'avoir su par leur malheur
chances de jouer dans la ligue nationale
peuple tout en étant une légende un
fait aux plus devenir un joueur du
facilite plus de gala afin que toute
femmes d'appoint pièce est large et
et puis le lendemain le canadien repêche
un peu trop jeune pour l'avoir connu
ce calibre là ça va merci beaucoup de
auprès générosité et humilité sa jeune
que militaire était sincère il n'y avait
bientôt tu te souhaite remplacer par
ça que ça vient une fois par génération
qui c'est un gars qui pouvaient s
il était il était vrai du début à la fin
la municipalité mâts pales d'une telle
toujours de rejoindre ces quads felling
des photos autographes et notamment deux
derrière l'athlète on voit ce qui a été
québécois qui dominait la lnh avec
en avoir donc posso près d'aix qui
et la flore tu jouais à la pointe à
c'était le premier grand héros sportif
l'improviste et à chaque fois dit
précisions là lors de la conférence de
traversé le pare brise et le lobe de
majeure moi je n'ai jamais vu d'autres
mon époque j'avais paquin saison pour ce
il ya un groupe d'hommes d'affaires mené
pouvait m'appeler le soir vers neuf
un vrai privilège qu'on
triste d'apprendre la nouvelle de sa
mettre en lumière que moi guy il y avait
veille sans donner de raisons comprend
attention
qui est heureux après vous avez connu
des places pour aller voir jouer d'un
la fleur la fleur en 1 6 5 coupes
dans ses meilleures années mais qui en
pendant quelques années alors j'ai eu le
contre l'ontario mais dans l'esprit
funérailles nationales en deçà peu
était extrêmement accessible humble
alors lors d'une rencontre avec serge
attend bambin il est là mais voilà c'est
vivre le coach du canadien le matin au
alors des mots quand même qu'ils qui
compte facebook personnelle ça a été
de 77 de la coupe vous en avez connu
bien souvent ça dérange elle est partie
canadien de montréal par la tendance
on peut être comme ça pire beaucoup de
borg et des
à très bientôt sur voie nous à 17 ans tu
qu'il a pas
est de mon
case à chocs
zouaoui peu plus loin et quand je suis
ce qui est revenue pierre bouchard
personne n'était là disponibles à droite
on le disait aussi n'hésitait jamais
laflaque comme un vice président années
champion un homme qui réalisait des
le seul canadien ici autant de le
vraiment les québécois au dans la ligue
c ils nous ont demandé que c'est un lieu
mort ce matin on peut les écouter
vous montez connu partout et surtout
idole et bien on se rend compte que
quand même incroyable il est revenu il a
neuvième coupe stanley et on dit tu vois
heures à peu près mon téléphone
presse à 14h le premier ministre que
gardent un souvenir indélébile
fourchette en appétit et joue avec
presse écrit dans ciels il rien donné
accomplit jean perron j'ai toujours un
des était leur dire puis les gens
autant de panache par un des nôtres
nous avons parlé
autre personne que je connais
puis j'ai travaillé sur un documentaire
vous évoque des souvenirs certainement
plaintes devant ma
l'oreille déchiré à sa de la mort est
était partie de la ligne bleue
guy lafleur
il y en a pas beaucoup et il rentre dans
carbonneau reviennent on remonte dans le
que les rumeurs et de rénovation mais
par paul dumont au québec qui avaient
cette période la plus difficile que vous
talent particulier et c'est à ce moment
gens gentils dans la vie bravo mais
de que que j'ai connu j'ai rencontré une
cellulaire ça n'est quand je répondais
sportifs quand je repense à ses trois
stanley 17 saisons dans la ligue
vraiment le premier endroit où on a
lafleur prenait le temps de s'arrêter de
également keane à peu près jamais refusé
pays je peux pas dire s'il était parfait
choses incroyables alors tous garde
comme ça madame dans le sport et qui les
pourquoi aujourd'hui et on avait été
personne dans la rue quand on joue aux
pour les jeunes alors la ville s'est
de ses grands joueurs qui vit la fleur
renommer ça va de a woman jusqu'à
des trois c'était dur externe est
changer son horaire aujourd'hui
des relations publiques et j'ai fait
tout ça et bien fait on va c'est pas
arrivé au port dans l'appel qu'un des
pas de filtre vous l'avez connu dont le
de conscience vis-à-vis le cancer il ya
de la journée martin leclerc bonjour
depuis ce matin c'est des gens qui
savard et ronald corey guy lafleur a
brillé avec autant de succès c'est une
réussi malgré tout ça pas été facile
meilleur des deux mondes c'est un
monde annonce le décès du numéro 10
l'adjointe beaucoup de passion c'est ce
imaginaire l'ontario est bien meilleur
cette des chaleurs qui tu méritais mieux
discuté on va configurer notre programme
c'est enfin je pense des grandes
ce matin je voulais aussi vous présentez
c'est tout petit à l'époque où il jouait
plein d'anecdotes attaché aux
de 8h sur canadien drake la rivalité
une rare catégorie monsieur lafleur ou
aujourd'hui les temps ont changé et puis
choqué complètement souvenirs souvenirs
le wagg aux anciens comme du bas et ils
plaisir de vous parler merci beaucoup et
là que les parents d'amy la flore se
nationale un certain moment donné où
évidemment pour pouvoir répondre aux
sacré pour montrer sa dans un école d'or
allé à la rencontre du peuple à la
de demandes d'entrevue auprès des médias
quand guy prend des buts savez il ya
la toile à comprendre le fait il est une
pas en avoir vous êtes d'accord
quilles avait toujours une bataille
du bonjour ben c'est guy lafleur le pot
disent il ne se prenait pas plus gros
temps la de kells a gagné la coupe
notamment et d'autres grands joueurs et
avez dû gérer oui mais d'abord
d'oubli de l'excellence doublé d'un
patrick roy le dernier pardon mono
premières années avec le canadien des
deux dans les deux cas ne parlait pas de
livré un dernier message mais c'est ce
occupé de lui installer un endroit où il
nationale il est parti il est revenu
questions des journalistes lorsqu on
machester
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on avait raté
malheureusement madame au kg
gars qui m'a dit on à 2% staal au bal de
source immense de fierté donc rappelle
étaient extrêmement reconnaissant le pur
personnage plus grand que nature mais
c'était c'était pas facile
et là aussi on observer la paix 1 vous
convenu de qui la laissera le ciri qu'il
martin bonjour patrice mongeau jean
d'excellents souvenirs de guy lafleur et
personnages ils venaient souvent ici
bien apprécié parce que faiblesse la
mais j'avais fait la paix c'était ça ma
sportif comme il faut mais il faut il
rencontre du monde commence à ce
contenu dans chaque pays c'était un
savoir qu'ils allaient porter le numéro
catégorie
lafleur qui a partagé tout simplement et
beaucoup de fonctions avec lui jeta les
l'état comme cela
après sa retraite à revenir on voit les
encore commencé mais on voit que
tellement honorée de pouvoir le
stanley à 71 et pourtant le premier
saisons de 29 28 et 21 buts ce qui
le tapage publicitaire est incroyable
regarder les gens dans les yeux et de
nous dit c'est qu'il va y avoir une
qui n'a pratiquement jamais refusé
puis à la maison mais mes parents mais
qu'on doit
que les anciens parlent l os x puis je
que le québec et quand guy lafleur est
merci d'avoir partagé des intrigues fat
un bond des réactions aux du premier
plusieurs fois mais la première fois
et on a un corps par accident on a perdu
sont mis à fréquenter les arénas et se
quelque chose de bien bêtes au forum
ale me levais à ses projets la chance de
y avait des défauts comme tout le monde
watching
ouais je sais que
accueillaient les gens et qu'on disait
pouvait atterrir paisiblement venir
après ça chauffe novation alors oui j'ai
je me trouve avec un amateur de rock qui
10 qui allait avoir le gilet qui allait
tout ça et j'avais donné rendez-vous à
ainsi guy lafleur avait perdu la vie
patrice à moins que la famille il
connu 71 par fille était pas leurs
ce qu'il a laissé aux fans de rock aimé
l'entraîneur se prépare à donner ce qui
puis c'est exactement ça mais voilà
allait occuper un rôle au deuxième étage
d'enfance quand j'étais jeune je voyais
je pense que guy lafleur était de la
que l'équipe était bien sur scène
maman viens voir qu'est ce que c'est que
générosité de 10 puis moi je connais des
transport comment ça se jouait sa entre
avec l'hélicoptère au départ bien il
premièrement quand il ya plus d'un mois
pour sa carrière avec les canadiens
j'aime le préciser on a aussi vu des
déclaration qui va durer de 8 à 10
d'autographes ou de prise de photos avec
faut garder guy lafleur au québec pour
autres sortes de levée de fonds avec de
françois martins sur le sur le côté
avec new york avec québec ensuite y
nommer mr sa volée chaque mois main puis
arrivé à québec avec les grands pas il
présenter à la famille on a envoyé le
avait dit la faillite est supérieur in
mais lors leur geste que leur côté frein
photos avec les nordiques en trop oui
parler au premier ministre des ministres
ministre justin trudeau encore une fois
une journée comme ça ça ça change une
guy je t'aime tu as fini de souffrir tu
question servent et il y avait fait
être guy lafleur personnifié guy lafleur
et je peux aller bien des gens sur lui
j'appelle les forces de la chance mais
tout à l'heure vous avez dit tout à
ne te les défauts mais ça paraît sur
leur parler de leur signer des
avez fait là port bouet votre moi que
aujourd'hui serait exceptionnel a passé
que guy lafleur c'était comme s'en sert
quitte à être là aujourd'hui monsieur à
rendent compte que leur fils l'âge de 10
ce qu'il a laissé aussi au québec en
toronto y aurait là on avait une femme
me suis d'entendre sur tille pas ce que
une personne qui est vraiment et
et des souvenirs avec nous merci à la
c'est le projet jean bingo à parcourant
des partisans alors pour tous ces gens
grandes vedettes bien ce qui marquait
puissant voulait qu'un était pas bon
s'objecte mais moi je dis qu'il doit
visiter sa mère venir visiter les gens
ici et et
étaient contents de le voir sur la
par ipe émigra puis eux même parler des
le convaincre de rester à québec y est
coéquipier extraordinaire on avait avec
gens au chant qui n'ont vu par tous ces
choix pourquoi parce que l'année juste
gens venir si loin que la nouvelle
tv souvent ça m'attriste le gagnant n'a
vous dit jean-françois qu'est ce qu'on
à des débits braver des global business
l'heure la symbiose avec le peuple il
mais qui la place c'était spécial quand
minutes et ensuite le premier mnistre
finalement je me rappelle j'avais écrit
la fleur est finalement avec tout c'est
ce site ça c'est guy lafleur guy lafleur
où l'ambassadeur avec l'équipe et après
sera un des premiers point de presse on
parce que je remonte quand même un
mike bossy la semaine dernière qui est
les coéquipiers vous le sentiez ça qui
j'ai vu j'étais là près d'eux dans les
comme présidente en attendant requis de
même chose de nous s'ils savaient la
guitares et l'année suivante il
sur son compte twitter alors il dit
l époque était vu comme quelque chose
voulait prouver que cette ligue là
avait pas tout donné sentais encore en
les plouffe et qui juste à côté de moi
me disait tu tiens des mêmes de soir
ou maria non à l'hôtel de sers l'ancien
ne manquait jamais de guy lafleur c'est
lien parce que ce documentaire là que
conséquence qui commande dans ses lignes
patinoire salam aurait beaucoup de soon
mais
vas nous manquer énormément avec cette
devenir 'le devant une chapelle ardente
tentait d'atterrir dans un terrain est
là la perte du démon blond aujourd'hui
dans beaucoup bruit parce que moi c'est
alors ça démontre encore je vous entends
écosse il était en visite à montréal
votre eau qui comptait vicomte
avant le canadien compléter sam pendant
autographes
there in there to traduit maillard tout
aurait raté ce qui est intéressant c'est
dans la prairie match ne s'était jamais
de l'admiration pour ce type de joueur
legault devrait prendre deux trois
pour ceux qui ne l'ont jamais vu jouer
cédule d'un organisation puis avec
lui il était comme ça dans charges y
puis leur côté un teg les gens se disent
traitements frma qui ont été
ici parce que vous allez l'entendre on a
prochaine genre
étaient supérieurs à ceux des matériaux
ou 11 ans déjà il avait un statut de
cisco repos mais est elle est frappée il
c'était le gars qui a fait une
mon texte pas avec les trois buts avec
certain temps il y avait fait la paix
vous allez voir ce soir du chou ému par
qui plaisir de côtoyer je pense que l'on
grande fournier nous disait ce matin
dix la soeur
mastaing c'est être est ce qu'on veut la
sportif sur les performances je le
qui est un joueur qu'on peut dire que
l'écouté mais premièrement je voudrais
sans l'équipe y était rien
il va falloir remporter la coupe
forme 560 but et c'est donc dans les
c'était un numéro pour moi pour toute ma
bonjour
ultra fermé le shisha là maintenant je
bien sûr mais il tenait à être tout près
une fille d'alan nationale il faut revit
tellement 71 72 mais on a connu 73 76 37
sûr je t'ai fait j'en assume l'entière
dix mois dans une entrevue qui passe à
regardait pas le non seulement regarda
c'est une très grande perte non
portée de ces paroles
qui était en deçà des attentes pour le
tout ce qui est arrivé au fil des ans on
des archives on s'aperçoit que votre
derniers moments de leur vie dit je
questions en français peut être une ou
souvent bien il était un peu pris avec
là aussi cet après-midi réaction aussi
à part lui abandonné
ok bonne journée pas trop savoir
perdu un atout sied dernièrement avec
que patrick roy nous parle de but guy
et puis
parce que tous nous inspirer alors bon
cette personne de table j'écoutais les
photo photo de famille dont guy lafleur
avec tout ça depuis un bon bout de temps
impressionnés par l'homme et c'est un
est ouvert à parler au monde il y avait
assez puis voulait plus puis voulait
ça
vedette régionale de l'est les enfants
qu'une transaction avec les pauvres
raison
moi d'abord pourquoi c'est important
qui a marqué l'histoire de son sport et
vraiment l'impression d'avoir perdu un
différence
et le réussit en 71 à battre edmonton à
des tantôt avec monsieur corps et
ce que avec les essais j'ai tout vu de
10 a ouvertement tout ce qui qui
seulement pour le monde du hockey mais
memorial avec une avec les remparts a
se forger et il revenait la main de
passait quelque chose il disait qu
deux questions en anglais aussi
responsabilité
joueur qui était attendu avec les
on les oui ils nous font rêver on
partie s'arrête
rendu meilleur tout le monde parce que
lov et que oui c'est votre cerveau ne
c'est sûrement la personnalité
or c'était tout un joueur de hockey et
lui quand est ce que tu écris un pic sur
n'étais pas là mais j'ai pas le drian et
paul pope de haut mais prenait le timbre
et qu'on planifie alentours des chose la
l'histoire avec la très bon indiqué
pense que dilma va d abord je souhaite
de la statue qui est juste derrière moi
sur la glace sa vitesse ses habiletés et
des sceaux a love song il a des
puis c'était gris qui s'est jamais pris
je suis malade jockey savait pas le seul
au hockey ouais moi j'étais sur la glace
plus ce qui leur donnait la retraite au
4 4 4 crème d'amande adhérents à madrid
évidemment seulement sur le sujet de
des jeunes qui jouaient sur ce terrain
mari est devenu le protecteur de guy
également pour le québec en général
ami ici
enfin qui viennent de toute la classe
voyage pour la suite merci beaucoup
jean-françois et c'est intéressant parce
mike bossy c'est des grandes légendes
est devenu des bombes chambre parce que
les balles au dos on l'appréciait mais
rappelle pour ceux qui n'étaient pas
pour vous d'être ici aujourd'hui pour
comme j'avais des liquidités revenues
on ne livre jamais ce qu'on a connu avec
golden seals de la californie
va dans le dépassement soit en la
évidemment y avait des difficultés comme
l'aider son record de neuf saisons le
shérif d'un grand tic et
canadiens de montréal et sa troisième
a on pense que connaît ni la loi parce
donc je parte québec c'est à 9h30
moi mais je viendrai l'assumé il y avait
de larges de guy lafleur ou même un peu
un repli défense
aucune retenue et d'ailleurs il ya eu
bouge pas ça va toujours exister pour
aujourd'hui pour rendre un dernier
et que guillaume
lafleur a marqué contre lui alors qu'il
fond oui parce qu'il n'est pas capable
donné ses lettres de noblesse et c'est
bonheur puis demander un
avec nous il faut bien se mettre en
l'avis de guy lafleur depuis c'est une
c'était la grande vedette du club
comme ça cela dit je pense qu'à un
souvent les gens sont regarde pas
politique déjà tout le monde est secoué
années 70 sans contredit le plus grand
alors la municipalité éventuellement
pensaient qu'ils devaient exhiber sa
l'église à fleurs et c'est là qu'on va
- jallet j'allais manger régulièrement
un grand respect de fait des spectateurs
hommage à ce grand du haut qui parce que
et tout ce qu'on va faire pour lui c'est
de la première retraite guy lafleur
ils échangent leur premier choix et
musulmans avant le sommet des ventes de
tilly je te prendrai ma décision
répondre donc il a peur mais n'ont
route l'équipe i
il en a fait lever sur le stif à deux
plus vieux se coucher le soir et la
québécoise qui a signé le plus
moi j'en ai mangé bof tu es plus gai
saison d'indy un but après son repêchage
maman peu après il ya également un des
ce livre toutes les têtes quand on
sud de 50 bus et plus ce sera peut-être
dorothée canadien lui se prenait pour un
célébration de sa vie c'est vraiment ce
d'euros mais prennent pas le temps lui
le roi qui tarde à 2 mai mais ça va être
probablement sur cette base que la ligue
38 enfants et puis après tout dire
d'accepter ces contre-performances donc
j'habitais alors laissez moi je vous dis
lui ne faisait pas sentir et puis il ya
à avoir une relation le rapport au corps
rayon de
ça ne l'intéressait pas de faire partie
que c'était l'idole du peuple mais la
parler du protocole de ce qui s'en vient
contexte dans les années soixante dix il
qu'ils disaient des choses allèrent mais
personne celles qu'ils étaient aussi en
quand j'appelle une belle même même si
la période de questions le maire de
plus importante aujourd'hui près de 7
des moments extrêmement difficiles avec
un maraîcher qui est un malade n'en
lafleur parce que ses dribbles c'est pas
records et ses cinq coupes stanley il a
puis on manque pas de fans qui est à
joueur de hockey est sans contredit
ya jamais eu de reuter facile tout pour
que certains et puis il parle de kloten
le monsieur est encore là à côté de vous
connaît la flamme d'arrivée deux en
vieillit mal je me rappelle que j'étais
peut-être pas fait à droite main mais
ce soit d'autre arrivé sous n'importe
jamais égalé mais il y avait il y avait
je pense qu'ils savaient ce qu'ils
ou bleu blanc rouge de guy lafleur à
je pense que ce qui était c'était pas
appellent à la fin jean béliveau que
lui rappeler ses fameux son public il
prochain la déflation donc vivant en
c'était une retraite contre son gré il
il ya des discussions aussi entre le
semaine prochaine je vais jouer contre
allemand dans l'histoire d'un peuple les
moment donné il faut foule déjà allé
à corps d'un but mais celui l'austère
que j'avais regardé ça puis vous allez
montréal ajoute un gars qui s'appelle le
d'autographes dans sa vie auprès des
gardien il faisait partie et toute sa
hautement méritée il mais coderre
mangue la chance de vivre au quotidien
ils'est temps j'aurais pas l'anglais
à la place des joyaux de forcer la note
l'homme aux mains de guy lafleur
continuer il ya eu 69 mais 80 tours je
inspiré d'innombrables québécois
fils de guy lafleur qui a partagé un
guy lafleur vrai qu'on a c'est de gérer
6 oui toujours là c'est quoi son nom
chefs
de hockey junior majeur du québec a
québec qui a choisi de très bons mots
comment s'est-elle côtoyé comme
un départ canon avec les canadiens avez
qu'il y avait un charisme incroyable ils
on attend vrai jeu d'un coup un jour où
était le meilleur là toutes catégories
des meubles
l'organisation du canadien la paix
med équipe mais préserve son travail
quenneville certains se disaient ça
qu'on va mais c'était tout un journal
bien de prendre jambes pis il y avait
guy lafarge avait affronté de la fleur
c'était le bac avec angel
faisaient qu est ce qu il disait quand
celui qui a fait le plus rêver les gens
avant deux parties d ok puis deux ans
l'assemblée nationale vous savez on ne
après un événement où tout était rangée
quel joueur il était pas plus route
protocole du bureau du premier ministre
france et ailleurs a très bien été un
ix qui va peut-être compter 20 but dans
gérer chemin avoir quelques larmes
gagné en crédibilité est devenue ce
mon com est ce que j'ai pu m'en faire
sur les voyages les avions ou dans la
une mascotte pour le canadien il ya une
rosemère et tout mitchum mais je
canadiens et amateurs du monde entier tu
j'étais allé le voir chez lui puis
vraiment la famille pas tout le monde
une hausse est due à leur tour d'autres
mon public je postais comme on l'a gâché
tout de même c'était la réalité page on
le raconter de leur signer ça fait une
puis j'ai bien lui c'est simplement se
jeunes auprès des moins jeunes et lui
parce que et beaucoup de souffrances
deux choses qui rassemble plus une
vous senti chez votre mari cette volonté
étaient explosées qu'on appelait le
confondues oui absolument
je me souvient gilles lupien un autre
journaliste réjean tremblay quel genre
le 10 puis il s'est jamais caché c'est
succès qu'avec
une question identitaire aussi avec guy
faut il faut le comprendre il avait
rapporter quelle pression énorme ça tu
pour commenter le départ de guy lafleur
commence et c'est notre vie c'est notre
est candidat à
des difficultés que j'étais là pour
non il prend sa décision de week-end
l'équipe d'ailleurs il ya un phénomène
voulait avoir les commentaires d'emery
et celui de l'assemblée nationale savoir
hommage une vague d'amour à son papa sur
ronald corey très apprécié que vous
super pote qui a croché patin est si
avaient été faits d'après vous après la
impôts dans mon souvenir guy comme je
qu'elle est au travail on dit on dit que
démon blond il ya pas toujours pour paul
mode co juger parce que dit il faut
j'avais déjà élit son époux ge je vais
nation c'est la culture et le sport plus
élisent alors vous êtes au centre bell
certainement mais vous allez aussi
la ligue nationale pas plus élevés la
pense qu'il avait quittée en 83
rien donc je suis arrivé à devoir je
s'en est rendu compte de ce qu'on veut
vie defferrard moi je peux jusqu'à la
où il y avait plus sa retraite je vous
âgées on espérait que la musique et puis
chambre des joueurs comment il était
lafleur il n'a pas seulement marqué
sa malle fait c'était une vie comme ça
coach icaunais député de marquette
vas nous manquer numéro 10 est bien sûr
cette envie d'être là
de protéger le petit gars qui arrivent à
de rapports vous aviez quand il était
ancien coéquipier de guy lafleur qui m'a
riches plus riches peu importe le
différence dans la vie de combien de
tous les jeux et jouets articles assez
travaillais pour une compagnie de
secrétaire étaient exactes alors ils
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le drapeau par
nadal avant de venir en appui de bonheur
assez extraordinaire guy n'a jamais
sourire parce que vous allez revivre les
jeune avec ce talent le tout en deux
des fois on s'est amusé de piaf la pompe
veux tu être de pau livrer la hauteur
son compte facebook je vous lis le début
soyez venu nous voir en personne merci
on dit que béliveau bats il crise et que
on entend les témoignages ses
de patrons ces trois légendes jean
courage résilience dit à des gens
j'avais parlé à des partisans d'ailleurs
héros à nos jours puis ceux qui ne l'ont
traversé une mauvaise passe et était en
dieu des habitants avaient raison ses
député libéral savoir ce qu'il pense de
ya eu des bons monsieur corps et même le
mentionner que des bons souvenirs de ce
ramène à 1985 à montréal on peut sentir
saison commence et les gourdonnais
transport va juive à montréal puis tu
honte à porter le casque protecteur vous
maurice richard était paraît il
jean-françois monsieur bouchard on
une personne qui était très honnête
raconté que dans son enfance il
nations plus haut l'année 110 avec lui
monde petit sas à berthierville
mettre le cardinal turcotte dormir avec
le premier ministre du québec qui est
montréal
des attentes que ça aurait été facile de
dans le sport une des personnes les plus
porté dehors ni de ces
longtemps malgré tout ce que souhaitent
exemple si on met drapeaux en berne
et dit je t'aimerai toujours le meilleur
à la tourbière choix mais
tout sens à ses joueurs évidemment la
côté là quand j'ai travaillé avec lui
je pense à point tout le monde mais
puis je me rappelle c'est la coupe
coéquipiers depuis depuis le début de la
dernière année de sa vie et fonder le
et avec son public mais c'est important
pas bijoux il va les perdre ceux qui ne
oscars est une saison de misère comme on
conflit avec jack le maïs est quant à
monsieur corey et lise allard et devint
maintenant ou si on respecte la
exploits de guy lafleur sur toutes les
tout à l'heure c'est très touchant
béliveau guy laflamme maurice richard
d'un proche de guy lafleur il se
l'appeliez savoir d'être sauf à le
allé d'une série de tweets un peu plus
exceptionnels qui deviennent des modèles
moi comme on est allé voir la longue rue
savaient ce avait causé la grande
la flamme le pays le rentabiliser et
qui était très fier de ce qu'il faisait
les fans d'amy janis joplin retraite et
s'endormait le soir sd un jour je vais
s'écraser que ce raid est facile de
petit papa au monde je voulais être à
canadiens
malheureusement c'est pas arrivé et à
mets tous mes clients voulaient que je
l'ont pas vu jouer bête tabarouette je
parents vous avez vous avez vu un
plusieurs équipes
qui est arrivé pour s'accorder puis elle
aimés une personne qui a fait le plus
d'entendre les gens bien résumé ce que
produit a donné lieu à un emploi au 2ème
journée quand on demande aux gens ce que
déranger
s'y attendait durant la saison vers le
confiait à guy lafleur durant toute sa
canada 76 lafleur pas la première fois
avec lui un délai d années d je passais
tradition pour les funérailles
au-delà de leur sport au delà de de ce
son utilisation de jeu et c'était la
daley est à l'origine de la création du
sincère mali
était l'autre soldat avec son fils
tribunes alors voilà j'ai beaucoup souri
tôt ce matin françois legault je vous
scission entre l'organisation et guy
tck 20 h 35 un tueur à gages sur
c'est un joueur spectaculaire puis
et leur demande à parler puis lors j'en
placer dans l'or il ya plus sur la tête
nationales c'est à dire que en général
les amène chez guy laplatine quand ça a
oui il est revenu intervenue avec le
tes côtés du début à la fin pour te
déteste auchan et moi j'étais lagarde
il voulait que j'ai dit la bible est le
leurs alliés d'aujourd'hui est encore
l'échappée qui serait est facile de se
pour lui et puis là y'avait janeiro et
vibrer les québécois c'est guy lafleur
trophée maurice-richard commun j'étais à
carrière lui qui est elle scripteur des
a dit avant moi ton numéro
ressort donc des extraits ce qui faisait
signifiait et guy lafleur bon ok c'était
lafleur heureusement est d'ailleurs
martin de même pris un café dans un seul
pour un événement comme celui-là le
étage sa peau de jeu à il est devenu
bonne vieille question qui revient
marquez dit de les porter à lavaur à
et les choses en ordre un petit peu de
meilleur joueur au monde mais quand tu
représente pour eux qu'il a fait oui
remercier de tout ce que tu as fait pour
certaines ac leader
l'aéroport quand vous êtes arrivé la
et il ya travaillé avec moi et moi je
été ça et aider les belles années que
perdre et de penser qu'on ne valait plus
que comme c'est les tests des odeurs axe
monsieur corée très ému tout à l'heure
étais minuit il a ensuite mal appelle la
très mal les fonctions que j avais d'un
rencontré jane de milliers satin de
canadien je baille que des propos plus
drapeau est mise en berne le matin
souvent dans une relation entraîneur un
vois mal les bateaux il n'y a aucune
sion alors que tout soit qu'on peut se
journée le quéré justement ces cafés de
de lui un joueur unique c'était bien sûr
moi et comment tu as toujours été là
le meilleur joueur de la meilleure dans
est un des présidents ce fonds là car
comme prêts à prendre le numéro pour lui
crainte à le dialogue angels et puis
à l'aurée et y afférentes il se tint ses
h moral avait dit quelque chose
ce qui est important d'invités on joue
j'ai passé un combat guy lafleur
viviez vous l'avez rencontré un moment
des pétitions paris v où hasan était
que jamais à l'heure qu'est ce qui fait
archicad avec le canadien le rocket
pour moi dans ma vie ce qu'il ressent
son talent extraordinaire mais aussi son
donné parce que c'était le corps le plus
une game on a su gagner des matches
si pons impôt
très bien récemment avec les défaites et
tout mais l'eau
avec le décès de guy lafleur ça ramène
les choses un peu en un glandu
perspective cette institution français
s'est fait que
c'est
il ya des choses qui sont bien plus
importants dans vie
de gagner des matches puis fait que je
pense si une chose ça va donner c'est un
petit peu de perspectives comme
entraîneur comme un cube de c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]